Sunday, 28th of November, I breakfasted with Mr. Douglas. I went to St. James' Church and heard service and a good sermon on, By what means shall a young man learn to order his ways, in which the advantages of early piety were well displayed. What a curious, inconsistent thing is the mind of man. In the midst of divine service, I was laying plans for having women, and yet I had the most sincere feelings of religion. So that was James Boswell writing in his journal six months before his fateful meeting with Samuel Johnson,
11月28日，星期日，我和道格拉斯先生一起吃了早餐。我去了圣詹姆斯教堂，听了礼拜和一篇很好的布道，题目是“年轻人当何以修其身”，其中很好地阐述了早年虔诚的好处。人类的心灵真是奇妙而矛盾。在礼拜进行正酣时，我竟然在盘算着去寻花问柳，然而我又怀有最真诚的宗教情感。这是詹姆斯·博斯韦尔在他命运般地结识塞缪尔·约翰逊六个月前写下的日记，
the hero of this story in Thomas Davis's bookshop. So Boswell had begun this great journal, one of the most glittering, scintillating records of life in the 18th century ever written, arguably the most complete record of what it's like to live in the 18th century. he'd begun this enormous project two weeks earlier. But who was this young man who was sitting in church having all these fantasies about having women during the sermon of all moments? Shocking. Tom, tell all.
也就是托马斯·戴维斯书店里这个故事的主角。当时博斯韦尔刚刚开始写这部伟大的日记，这是18th世纪有史以来最闪耀、最迷 人的生活记录之一，可以说是关于18世纪生活面貌最完整的记录。他在两周前刚刚开始这个宏大的项目。但这个年轻人是谁呢？他居然坐在教堂里，在偏偏是布道的时候做着各种寻花问柳的白日梦。太令人震惊了。汤姆，把一切都说出来吧。
Well, as people will be able to tell from your accent, James Boswell is a young Scott. He's 22 years old at this point. He's stocky and build. And there's a hint of fleshiness, I think, in his face, perhaps a precursor of how he will look in middle age. But he's very kind of mobile in expression. People always comment on this. And he has a face that many years later, a judge who had known him, would describe as impossible to look upon without being moved by the comicality which always reigned upon it.
嗯，正如大家从你的口音中能听出来的，詹姆斯·博斯韦尔是个年轻的苏格兰人。此时他22岁。他身材敦实。而且我认为他的脸上有一丝肉感，或许预示着他中年的长相。但他的表情非常生动。人们总是对这一点津津乐道。多年后，一位认识他的法官曾这样形容他的面庞：如果不为那总是洋溢其上的滑稽感所触动，便不可能直视这张脸。
He looks fun. Not only does he look fun, but he is fun. People like him very, very instinctively. and he's just arrived in London when he put it down that journal entry that you read from Edinburgh and honestly he couldn't be more thrilled about it. So the journey from Edinburgh down to London had taken him three days. It had been quite brutal. They'd kind of lost a wheel outside Berwick and so on. And so when they arrive, Boswell, well, he writes in his journal, when we came upon Highgate Hill and had a view of London, I was all life and joy. And he had given three hussars. Oh, lovely. We love a man who gives three hussars when he's happy, I think. So just to remind people what this story is, it's the story of Samuel Johnson and James Boswell.
他看起来很有趣。他不仅看起来有趣，而且确实很有趣。人们非常非常本能地喜欢他。当他写下你刚才读到的那篇从爱丁堡出发的日记时，他刚刚抵达伦敦，说实话，他兴奋得无以复加。因此，从爱丁堡到伦敦的旅程花了三天时间。相当艰难。他们在贝里克城外掉了一个车轮等等。所以当他们抵达时，博斯韦尔——嗯，他在日记中写道：“当我们来到海格特山，望见伦敦时，我满心生机与喜悦。”他发出了三声欢呼。哦，太可爱了。我想，我们都喜欢一个在高兴时会欢呼三声的男人。所以提醒一下大家这个故事是什么，这是塞缪尔·约翰逊和詹姆斯·博斯韦尔的故事。
It's a brilliant window into friendship, into 18th century London, into 18th century Britain, this country that at this point is teeming with life and energy and excitement, it is becoming the most modern and the most powerful country in the world. And we're using their story as a way into telling that story. So, actually, London, he's giving the three hussars, isn't he, because London to Boswell represents the promised land. It's everything he's ever hoped for. Yeah, so it offers him glamour, and Boswell loves glamour. So he takes rooms in the very centre of things in Downing Street, where the Prime Minister lives now. But he's using it as a base for all kinds of things. So he's using it as a base for shopping. He goes out and buys what he describes
它是了解友谊、了解18世纪的伦敦、了解18世纪的英国的一扇绝佳的窗户。此时的英国生机勃勃、充满活力与兴奋，正成为世界上最现代、最强大的国家。我们正借用他们的故事来讲述那段历史。所以，事实上，伦敦，他发出了三声欢呼，不是吗？因为对博斯韦尔来说，伦敦代表着乐土。这是他一直以来所有的希望所在。是的，它为他提供了浮华，而博斯韦尔热爱浮华。因此，他在核心地带唐宁街租下了房间，也就是现在首相居住的地方。但他以此为基地开展各种活动。所以他把这里当作购物的基地。他外出购买了他所描述的
as a genteel, violet-colored frock suit. So he loves clothes. He meets lots of celebrities. He meets lots of Celebrities, we said in the previous episode, how Boswell is a great celebrity hunter. So he's hanging out with actors and poets and politicians and lords and all kinds of people like that. And he goes to lots of exclusive clubs. And of course, the 18th century loves a club. And he goes to one, the beefsteak club. Yeah. We had nothing to eat but beef steaks and had wine and punch in plenty and freedom. We had a number of songs. So it's very like the rest is history club, which people, if they're interested, they can head to the rest. is History.com to sign up. And they will get similar quantities of beefsteaks and songs, especially
一套优雅的紫罗兰色呢大衣。所以他热爱衣服。他遇到了许多名人。我们上一集说过，博斯韦尔是个狂热的名人猎手。所以他和演员、诗人、政治家、贵族以及各种各样这样的人混在一起。他去了很多高级俱乐部。当然，18th世纪的人们非常喜欢俱乐部。他去了一个，牛肉牛排俱乐部。是的。我们除了牛排什么也没吃，有充足的葡萄酒和宾趣酒，还有自由。我们唱了许多歌。所以这非常像“历史的剩余”俱乐部，如果大家感兴趣，可以前往therestisHistory.com注册。他们会获得等量供应的牛肉牛排和歌曲，尤其是
the rest is History Festival, which is this July at Hampton Court Palace. That is so expertly done. But Dominic, just to go back to the history, you did an episode on beefsteak, didn't you? Yeah, beef and liberty. So this is the kind of the dimension of London that Boswell, although a Scott, is very enthusiastically entering this notion of England as a home of liberty. London also represents to Boswell a sense of escape and opportunity. So he's just up in Edinburgh, his father is the law lord, very determined that Boswell is going to become a lawyer. Boswell has scraped through his law examinations, but he's come to London basically because he's hoping for a much more glamorous career, namely he wants to enter the guards and kind of tas around London in a bright red coat and all of that. That's also a crucial part of what has brought him to the capital.
“历史的剩余”节，将于今年七月在汉普顿宫举行。这做得太专业了。不过，多米尼克，回到历史本身，你做过一集关于牛肉牛排的节目，对吧？是的，牛肉与自由。所以这是博斯韦尔身上的伦敦维度，尽管他是个苏格兰人，但他非常热情地接受了英格兰作为自由之乡这一观念。对博斯韦尔来说，伦敦也代表着一种逃离和机会。他刚从爱丁堡上来，他的父亲是一位大法官，坚决要让博斯韦尔成为一名律师。博斯韦尔勉强通过了法律考试，但他来伦敦基本上是因为他渴望一个更光鲜的职业，也就是他想加入近卫军，穿着鲜红的外套在伦敦四处招摇，诸如此类。这也是促使他来到首都的一个至关重要原因。
but there isn't another aspect as well, which was hinted at. Well, more than hinted at, I mean, he's absolutely drawing attention to it in that sermon. And this is what Boswell elsewhere in his journal describes as the wars of the Paffian queen, by which he essentially means having lots of sex. So the Paffian queen is Venus. And Boswell in particular has a kind of, one could describe it perhaps as a bent for prostitutes. London, of course, at this point has multitudes of prostitutes. many of them are disease-ridden
但还有另一个方面，刚才也暗示过了。嗯，不仅仅是暗示，我的意思是，他在那场布道中绝对是在吸引人们对这一点的注意。这就是博斯韦尔在日记其他地方所描述的“帕菲安女王之战”，他基本上指的是进行大量的性行为。所以帕菲安女王就是维纳斯。而博斯韦尔尤其有一种，或许可以将其形容为对妓女的癖好。当然，此时的伦敦有着众多的妓女。她们中的许多人疾病缠身
and Boswell himself has already, as a result of this, caught the clap. And so he's nervous about getting it again. And in the early weeks of his arrival in London, he's actually incredibly impressed with what he describes as his own wonderful continents. On the 14th of December,
而博斯韦尔自己也因此已经染上了淋病。因此，他对于再次染病感到紧张。在抵达伦敦的最初几周里，他对自已所描述的“那种美妙的自制力”实际上印象深刻。在12月14日，
just a month or so after his arrival in London, it is very curious to think that I have now been in London several weeks without ever enjoying the delightful sex, although I am surrounded with numbers of free-hearted ladies of all kinds, from the splendid madam at 50 guineas a night, down to the civil nymph with white-thread stockings who tramps along the strand and will resign her engaging person to your honour
就在他抵达伦敦大约一个月后，“一想到我现在已经来伦敦好几个星期了，却从未享受过那令人愉悦的性趣，这真是极其奇妙，尽管我周围环绕着形形色色、思想开放的女士们，从每晚50基尼的奢华名媛，到穿着白线袜子、沿着斯特兰德大街蹒跚而行、愿意为了
for a pint of wine and a shilling. I feel that the pint of wine element would be off-putting for me. I feel like somebody who's advertising their wares for a pint of wine is... I think it's poor on all sides. I mean, I think the point is that Boswell is willing to go with whatever class of prostitute he can pick up. So this makes Boswell sound a very bad man. However, he is simultaneously desperate for moral guidance. I mean, he's fantasizing about women in church, but he is in church.
一品脱葡萄酒和一个先令就把迷人身段交给你阁下的文雅仙女。”我觉得一品脱葡萄酒这个元素会让我望而却步。我觉得那种用一品脱葡萄酒来兜售商品的人……我觉得这在各方面都很寒酸。我的意思是，重点在于博斯韦尔愿意和任何他能钓到的阶层的妓女鬼混。这让博斯韦尔听起来像个很坏的人。然而，他同时又极其渴望道德指导。我的意思是他在教堂里对女人想入非非，但他确实身在教堂。
What he really wants, I think, is someone to put him on the straight and narrow. He just wants to be loved. So he is, as his journal makes clear, a compound of contradictions and incompatibilities. and he traces these incompatibilities right the way through his journal. So he's a very open, gregarious, friendly man, but at the same time, he's very prone to deep melancholy. He's very bumpitious and self-regarding, so he's always making comments in his journal. I am one of the most engaging men that ever lived and clearly means it.
我想，他真正想要的是有人能引导他走上正道。他只是想被爱。因此，正如他的日记所表明的那样，他是一个充满矛盾和不相容特性的结合体。他把这些不相容性贯穿了整个日记。所以他是一个非常坦率、合群、友善的人，但与此同时，他又非常容易陷入深深的忧郁。他非常自负且自我感觉良好，所以他总是在日记里写道：“我是有史以来最迷人的男人之一”，而且显然是发自内心的。
But he's also very lacking in self-confidence. And as we've said, he's a prodigious womanizer, but he is looking to reform himself. And this, I think, is a crucial part of his fascination with great men, which would be a theme of this episode. It's not just that he's a celebrity hunter. It's more than that. He is looking for someone who can serve him as a mentor, as a kind of moral sheet anchor, if you like, stopping him from drifting and straying all over the place. And the person that he has long cast in that role is Samuel Johnson, who he talked about in the last episode, the great polymath man of letters from Litchfield in the West Midlands. And Boswell has looked up to him since he was a child.
但他同时也非常缺乏自信。正如我们所说，他是一个惊人的花花公子，但他正寻求自我改造。我认为，这是他迷恋伟人的关键部分，这也将是本集的主题。这不仅仅是因为他是个名人猎手。不仅如此。他在寻找一个能够充当他导师的人，一个能成为他某种精神锚点的人，防止他在各处漂泊和误入歧途。而他在很长一段时间里选定扮演这个角色的人是塞缪尔·约翰逊，我们在上一集中谈到过他，他是来自西米德兰兹郡利奇菲尔德的伟大学者兼文人。博斯韦尔从小就很崇拜他。
Yeah. So his father, who we will find out doesn't really approve of Johnson, nevertheless had copies of his moral essays in his library. And Boswell had read them, and they had given him this kind of idea of London as the home of this tremendous sage. And so I think that is also part of why Boswell has come to London. He has this fantasy that, in a sense,
是的。因此，他的父亲——我们后来会发现他并不真正赞赏约翰逊——尽管如此，他的书房里还是有约翰逊的道德散文集。博斯韦尔读过这些作品，它们赋予了他这样一种观念：伦敦是这位伟大智者的故乡。所以我认为这也是博斯韦尔来到伦敦的部分原因。他有一种幻想，从某种意义上说，
Johnson can provide him with the kind of father figure that his own father doesn't. Right. Because his father, Lord Affleck, this Scottish law lord, is a very intimidating man. And he's actually the opposite to Johnson. He doesn't really have much time for kind of literary men, which Johnson is. Lord Affleck is a wig and Johnson is a Tory. Lord Affleck is a Presbyterian and Johnson is an Anglican. And so there's a sense, I think, that Boswell coming to London, it's an overreact.
约翰逊可以为他提供他亲生父亲所无法给予的那种父爱形象。没错。因为他的父亲，奥斯勒克勋爵，这位苏格兰大法官，是一个非常令人畏惧的人。他实际上与约翰逊截然相反。他并不怎么能容忍约翰逊这种文人。奥斯勒克勋爵是辉格党人，而约翰逊是托利党人。奥斯勒克勋爵是长老会信徒，而约翰逊是圣公会信徒。因此，我认为有一种感觉，博斯韦尔来到伦敦，
overt act of rebellion against his father, really. I mean, he's proud of his, you know, his father, his lineage, all that kind of thing, isn't he, Boswell? He's not completely rebelling against the Boswell's. No, I mean, just the opposite. And this is another way in which Boswell is such a complicated man. Even as he's coming to London looking for a father figure, he remains incredibly proud of his father and inordinately proud of the entire Boswell name, as you suggest. So the Boswells are an ancient noble family. Boswell has a forefather who had died for the Scottish king at Flodden and he has a mother who, in a very tangential sense that Boswell is always harping upon, has a kind of relationship, a distant relationship to the Scottish monarchy.
实际上是对他父亲的一种公开叛逆。我的意思是，他为自己的父亲、自己的血统以及诸如此类的东西感到骄傲，不是吗，博斯韦尔？他并不是完全在背叛博斯韦尔家族。不，我的意思是，恰恰相反。这也是博斯韦尔如此复杂的一个方面。就在他来到伦敦寻找父爱形象的同时，正如你所暗示的那样，他依然为他的父亲感到无比骄傲，对整个博斯韦尔家族的名字感到异常自负。所以博斯韦尔家族是一个古老的贵族家庭。博斯韦尔有一位先祖曾为苏格兰国王战死在弗洛登，他的母亲与苏格兰王室有着某种远亲关系——博斯韦尔总是喋喋不休地谈论这种非常微弱的联系。
And he is particularly sentimental about the ancestral seat of the Boswells, which is his place, Affleck, which I'd always thought it was pronounced as it spelt, Orkenleck, but apparently it was Affleck. And this is set south of Glasgow, the rolling green hills of Ayrshire, north of Dumfries, and it has this tremendously romantic keep on a kind of gorge above the meeting place of two rivers. And even though Lord Affleck has just completed a very kind of fancy classical mansion, which is still standing there to this day, Boswell's heart is always going to be lying with the ruins. I felt a classic enthusiasm in the romantic shades of our family's seat. So Boswell is kind of, he's a snob, but he's a romantic snob.
而且他对博斯韦尔家族的祖屋有着特殊的伤感，那就是他的宅邸——奥斯勒克（Affleck），我以前一直以为它的发音和拼写一样是Orkenleck，但显然应该读作Affleck。它位于格拉斯哥以南，艾尔郡连绵起伏的绿色山丘间，在邓弗里斯以北，那里有一座非常浪漫的城堡，坐落在两条河流交汇处上方的峡谷上。尽管奥斯勒克勋爵刚刚建成了一座非常华丽的古典宅邸，至今仍屹立在那里，但博斯韦尔的心却永远留在了那些废墟中。“我在我们家族宅邸浪漫的树荫下感受到了一种古典的热情。”所以博斯韦尔某种程度上说，他是个势利小人，但却是个浪漫的势利小人。
Yeah, so he's born in 1740. So, you know, he's one of the first generations, I guess, to be really infused with the spirit of romanticism in some ways, that kind of nostalgic kind of sentimentality when you're looking at old ruins and all of that stuff. Which his father absolutely is not. His father does not approve of people who have, you know, lively imaginations and romantic leanings or indeed Toryism. And Lord Affleck is just unbelievably impatient with what he sees as his son's frivolity. So Boswell, we've said he's gregarious. Lord Affleck thinks he's much too gregarious, that he talks too much, that he laughs too loudly, that he's a show off. Lord Affleck, I'm afraid to say, is not a fan of impersonations and impressions. No, no. The lowest and meanest kind of wit. Yeah, terrible. And obviously, Lord Affleck is not amused by the fact that Boswell is already in debt, that he's having all these affairs, that he's having these periodic doses of the clap. This is not going down at all well with the Presbyterian. law lord. And so you can see, I think, why Boswell, even if he loves his father and admires him, might be looking around for someone slightly less challenging, perhaps, although actually the man he ends up with is also going to prove quite challenging. Pretty challenging if he's going to
是的，所以他出生于1740年。所以，你知道，我想他是第一代真正被浪漫主义精神所熏陶的人，在某种程度上，当看着古老的废墟以及所有这些东西时，会有一种怀旧的情感。而他的父亲绝对不是这样的人。他的父亲不赞成那些拥有活跃想象力和浪漫倾向，或者说托利党倾向的人。奥斯勒克勋爵对儿子身上那些他所看作轻浮的举动感到难以置信地不耐烦。所以我们说过博斯韦尔很合群。奥斯勒克勋爵认为他太合群了，话太多，笑得太大声，是个爱显摆的人。遗憾的是，奥斯勒克勋爵不是模仿和扮相的粉丝。不，不。这是最底层、最卑劣的幽默。是的，太糟糕了。显然，奥斯勒克勋爵对以下事实感到很不高兴：博斯韦尔已经负债累累，他有着各种各样的风流韵事，他周期性地感染淋病。这位长老会的法官对这一切感到非常不爽。所以你可以看出，为什么博斯韦尔即使爱戴和敬佩他的父亲，也可能会四处寻找一个稍微不那么具有挑战性的人，尽管事实上他最终遇到的人也将证明是相当具有挑战性的。如果他会
twitch at you. So the person he's got his heart set on is Samuel Johnson, who is obviously the opposite of his father in every way. He's kind of warm. Well, he's warm in his own way, I suppose. But he's a character, shall we say. But for the time being, Boswell puts his energies into, what does he call it, the Wars of the Pafian Queen. He does. Because he's been abstemious for the first few weeks, but eventually his resistance collapses. And he becomes particularly interested in an actress at the Covent Garden Theatre. And he gives her the pseudonym of Louisa. Yes. And the point about Louisa is that she's the daughter of quite well-born parents. And so Boswell assumes that not, you know, I mean, her beauty is obviously very important to him,
对你挑毛病的话，那就相当具有挑战性了。所以他一心认定的人是塞缪尔·约翰逊，他在各方面显然都与他的父亲截然相反。他很热情。嗯，他在某种程度上也算热情吧。但他是个很有个性的人，这么说吧。但目前，博斯韦尔把精力投入到了他所称的“帕菲安女王之战”中。确实如此。因为他在前几周一直很克制，但最终他的抵抗力崩溃了。他对科芬园剧院的一位女演员产生了浓厚的兴趣。他给她取了个化名叫路易莎。是的。关于路易莎，关键在于她是出身相当体面的父母的女儿。因此，博斯韦尔认为，（你知道的，她的美貌对他来说显然非常重要，
but so also is the very strong probability that she won't have gone a rear. Right. He thinks, I'm going to play it safe. I'm not going to go roaming around the streets. I'm going to stick with this beautiful actress. Sensible from him, I think. It's the first great tour de force in his journal, his account of this relationship with Louisa.
但同样重要的还有一种极大的可能性，那就是她不会乱来。）没错。他想，我要稳妥行事。我不会在街上乱晃。我要坚守这位美丽的演员。我认为他这样做很明智。这是他在日记中的第一个重大杰作，即他对与路易莎这段关系的描述。
It reads like a kind of mad novel, and it's kind of variously erotic, but also full of completely mortifying behaviour on the part of Boswell, all of which he details, without any sense of kind of inhibition at all. And I think it's worth looking at in some detail, because it gives you a real sense, not just of Boswell's character, but of his kind of genius as a writer of journals. So he's met up with Louisa, and in due course he is admitted into her rooms, and he finds her, as he describes it, in a pleasing undress.
读起来就像是一部疯狂的小说，既带有一种色情意味，又充满了博斯韦尔完全令人感到羞耻的行为，而所有这些细节他都毫不掩饰地详细描述了出来。我认为这非常值得仔细研读，因为它让你真正了解到的不仅是博斯韦尔的性格，还有他作为日记作家的天才之处。所以他与路易莎见了面，随后他被允许进入她的房间，正如他所描述的，他发现她穿着一身“令人愉悦的便装”。
At this point, both of them are kind of pretending to be shy, but both commit to future meetings. And so Boswell duly comes back. They sit down and they have a very titillating discussion about the different ways in which English and French men pursue amorous escapades. And of course, now it's starting to get a bit more titillating. Yeah, it's spicy. But it's still that kind of protracted courtship. You know, there are more meetings. But Boswell makes certain at their next meeting, as he puts it, to inform her by my looks of my passion for her.
此时，两人都在假装害羞，但都承诺将来还会见面。于是博斯韦尔如约返回。他们坐下来，进行了一场非常撩人的讨论，探讨英国人和法国人在追求浪漫冒险时不同的方式。当然，现在情况开始变得有些挑逗了。是的，很刺激。但这仍然是一种旷日持久的追求。你知道，还有更多的会面。但博斯韦尔在他们的下一次会面中，正如他所说的那样，确保“用我的眼神向她表达我对她的激情”。
And I don't quite know what that would mean. He looks at her. in a smouldering way. If you know how to do it, you know how to do it. Tom, what can I say? Yeah. So the visits continue, and on one of them, Boswell suddenly feels what he describes as the fine delirium of love.
我不太清楚这意味着什么。他用一种含情脉脉的眼神看着她。如果你知道该怎么做，你就会做。汤姆，我能说什么呢？是的。于是拜访仍在继续，在其中一次拜访中，博斯韦尔突然感受到了他所描述的“爱情的美妙狂喜”。
So he is now absolutely committed. Right. And on his next meeting, Louisa says, look, I'm a bit skint. Would you lend me two guineas? Okay, that's a red flag for me. And Boswell, feeling very gallant, does so. And then the next time he kisses her with great warmth, she received this very genteelie. I had a delicacy in Brazil.
所以他现在绝对是全身心投入了。没错。而在下一次见面时，路易莎说，听吧，我手头有点紧。你能借给我两基尼吗？好吧，对石我来说这是一个危险信号。而博斯韦尔感到非常绅士，于是照办了。然后在下一次，他热情地吻了她，她非常文雅地接受了。我在对待此事时表现得很细腻。
too far, lest it should look like demanding goods for my money. I resume the subject of love. So there's a certain caginess there. Noisa doesn't want to seem like she's selling herself, and Boswell doesn't want to look like if that's what he thinks she's doing. Yeah. But at this point, they agree to meet in two days' time where the affair will be consummated,
（过于谨慎了），以免看起来像是在用钱买货。我重新谈起了爱情的话题。所以这里面有一定的谨慎。路易莎不想让自己看起来像是在出卖自己，而博斯韦尔也不想让自己看起来把她当成那样的人。是的。但此时，他们同意在两天后见面，届时这段关系将水到渠成，
and so Boswell arrives full of excitement. But then, disaster. I felt the tormenting anxiety of serious love. He can't perform. Oh, no way. So he sits down beside her in despair. I would have given a good deal to be out of the room. And he gets up to go.
于是博斯韦尔满怀兴奋地赶去了。然而，灾难降临了。我感到了严肃的爱情所带来的折磨人的焦虑。他无法行房。哦，绝不可能。于是他绝望地在她身边坐了下来。我愿意付出很多代价来离开这个房间。他起身准备离开。
And he's about to leave. Then suddenly, saluting her with warmth, my powers were excited. I felt myself vigorous. Right. He's become more Scottish, as he's become more excited, which is interesting. She's smart. She plays him along. You know, she's still not surrendering to him.
正当他要离开时。突然，带着热情向她致意，我的力量被激发了。我感到自己精力充沛。没错。随着他变得更加兴奋，他变得更像苏格兰人了，这很有趣。她很精明。她一直在吊着他。你知道，她仍然没有向他屈服。
And she tells him such a thing requires time to consider of. And Boswell, of course, you know, she knows exactly what she's doing. Boswell is now, he finds himself really violently in love with Louisa. And the climax of this affair arrives at last on the 12th of January. Boswell's had a three-week courtship. And it's a long and very voluptuous night. Five times was I fairly lost in Supreme Rapture. And there's a lot more of that kind of thing.
她告诉他这种事需要时间考虑。而博斯韦尔，当然了，她很清楚自己在做什么。此时的博斯韦尔发现自己真的疯狂地爱上了路易莎。这场风流韵事的最高潮终于在1月12日到来。博斯韦尔经历了长达三周的追求。这是一个漫长而极其缠绵的夜晚。“我五次彻底迷失在至高的狂喜中。”还有很多类似的事情。
Yeah. And then the next morning, I love this. I patrolled up and down Fleet Street, thinking on London the seat of Parliament and the seat of pleasure, and seeming to myself as one of the wits in King Charles the Seconds time. So he's imagining himself as a restoration rake, and it's so Boswell that he's always kind of watching himself playing out roles. There's a sense in which the journal is operating on two levels. There's what Boswell is doing, and then there's Boswell watching himself, often in a state of kind of wonder at how brilliant he is. It's slightly disappointingly for Boswell, despite the five moments of rapture, almost immediately he decides that actually he's a bit sick of Louisa. I observed an affectation about her, which disgusted me. That's strong. After all that, geez, he's changed.
是的。然后第二天早上，我喜欢这个。“我在弗利特街上下巡视，想着伦敦是议会所在地和享乐之所，觉得自己就像查理二世时期的那些才子之一。”所以他把自己想象成一个复辟时期的浪子，这太博斯韦尔了，他总是看着自己在扮演各种角色。从某种意义上说，这本日记是在两个层面上运作的：一方面是博斯韦尔在做的事情，另一方面是博斯韦尔在看着自己，经常处于一种对自己有多么聪明的惊叹状态中。让博斯韦尔略感失望的是，尽管经历了五次狂喜的时刻，但几乎立刻他就决定其实自己有点厌烦路易莎了。“我在她身上发现了一种矫揉造作，这让我感到恶心。”这语气真重。经历了这一切之后，天哪，他变了。
I mean, again, you get the kind of the classic sense that the chase was all, and now he's caught his quarry. He's not as interested. But the fair goes on until then on the 20th of January, there is a disaster because he's been feeling a kind of, pain in his nether regions and he goes to the doctor and he is diagnosed with that distemper with which Venus, when cross, takes it into her head to plague her vultaries. He's got the clap. Yeah, Louisa's let herself down. Yeah. And so he goes to Louisa and she says, oh no, no, no, no, I'm not infected, I promise. And then she finally says, well, I did have it three years ago, but I'm completely cured. And Boswell is furious, but he then tells her, look, I'm not going to blacken your name by this, and he feels so pleased with himself for doing this. During all this conversation,
我的意思是，同样，你会有一种经典的感觉，即追求就是全部，现在他已经抓到了猎物。他没那么感兴趣了。但风流韵事仍在继续，直到1月20日，灾难降临了，因为他一直感到下体有一种疼痛，他去看医生，并被诊断出患了那种病：“当维纳斯发怒时，她会用这种病来折磨她的崇拜者。”他得了淋病。是的，路易莎太让人失望了。是的。于是他去找路易莎，她说，哦，不，不，不，我没有被传染，我保证。然后她终于说，好吧，我三年前确实得过，但我已经完全治愈了。博斯韦尔勃然大怒，但他随后告诉她，听着，我不会因此玷污你的名声——他为自己能这样做感到非常高兴。在这整个谈话过程中，
I really behaved with a manly composure and polite dignity that could not fail to inspire an awe. Well, that's good from him, but the next thing that happens, however, slightly undermines that, so yeah, so he's incredibly pleased with his kind of moral forbearance when he's with Louisa, but he then goes away and he starts to fulminate about it and get more and more irate, and then he starts thinking, I lent her two guineas, she's got the guineas, I want my guineas back. And so he writes her this incredibly priggish letter, send the money sealed up. I have nothing more to say to you. And Louisa then returns it. She had genuinely borrowed it. And so all Boswell's darkest thoughts are shown to be false. And he is briefly mortified. I felt a strange kind of mixed confusion.
我确实表现得有一种男子汉的沉着和优雅的尊严，这不能不令人敬畏。好吧，这从他嘴里说出来挺好，但接下来发生的事却稍微削弱了这一点，所以，是的——所以当他和路易莎在一起时，他对自己的那种道德克制感到难以置信的高兴，但他随后离开并开始对此大发雷霆，变得越来越愤怒，然后他开始想：“我借给了她两基尼，她拿了基尼，我要把我的基尼要回来。”于是他给她写了一封极其迂腐的信：“把钱密封好送来。我没什么好跟你说的了。”然后路易莎把钱退了回来。她确实是借的。因此，博斯韦尔所有黑暗的想法都被证明是错误的。他短暂地感到羞愧。“一种奇怪的混杂困惑感涌上心头。
My tender heart relented. I thought I had acted too harshly with her. And so he's feeling ashamed. But then the next day he mentions the whole story to a friend, he said it was just a piece of deep artifice in her. I resolved to think no more on the man. matter and was glad that I had come off two guineas better than I expected. I mean, to be fair to Louisa, she did give him the money back. Exactly. I don't think she comes out badly from their story particularly. No, but I mean, her gesture had made Boswell feel bad about himself.
我温柔的心软了下来。我觉得我对她太严厉了。”所以他感到羞愧。但第二天他向一个朋友提及了整个故事，他说这只是她深沉的诡计。“我决定不再去想这件事，并且庆幸自己的损失比预期的少了两个基尼。”我的意思是，公平地说，路易莎确实把钱还给他了。确实。我不认为她在他们的故事中表现得很糟糕。不，但我的意思是，她的举动让博斯韦尔对自已产生了不好的感觉。
And so he's now looking for reasons not to feel bad about himself and he finds one. And what's incredible about this is that he writes it all down in incredible detail so that we, two and a half centuries on, can exactly track the appalling way, which an incredibly human way in which he's responded to the whole shenanigans. So this was in January, all this, and the months have passed or the weeks have passed, and he's been feeling increasingly miserable, no doubt because of the after effects of the gonorrhea,
所以他现在正在寻找借口来让自己不再感觉糟糕，而且他找到了一个。而这其中令人难以置信的是，他把这一切都以难以置信的细节记录下来，以便我们两个半世纪后，能够准确地追踪到他应对整场闹剧时那种极其人性化、糟糕透顶的方式。所以这一切都发生在1月，时间一天天过去，或者说几周过去了，他越来越痛苦，毫无疑问是因为淋病的后遗症，
as much as anything. So he's actually just got sick of London, hasn't he? He thought London was brilliant, and now he's changed his mind. Yep. And what always happens with Boswell when he's depressed is that he basically goes on a kind of spree. Right.
很大程度上是这样。所以他实际上只是厌烦了伦敦，不是吗？他曾经认为伦敦棒极了，现在他改变主意了。是的。每当博斯韦尔情绪低落时，惯常的做法就是开始纵情狂欢。没错。
He surrenders to what he calls the foul fiend of the genitals. That is a foul fiend, yeah. And he's been walled up in his room, you know, getting over, he's gone and rea. Now he's come out and he's determined not to get it again. So when he goes out on the town, he wears what he calls armour, i.e. a kind of primitive condom. Yeah. And he's roaming St. James's Park where all the most glamorous prostitutes are to be picked up on the haymarket. And on one occasion, he actually takes a girl from the haymarket down to Westminster Bridge simply for the excitement of having sex with her with the Thames ruling below. us. He says it amused me much. So he's... Easily pleased. Well, I think a man who likes to spice up his pleasures in all kinds of strange ways. But this is a kind of index of his unhappiness. And he's depressed as well, not just that he's sinking into kind of dissipation, as he puts it. I mean, he doesn't feel great about what he's doing. He's still doing it, but he doesn't feel great about it. But he's depressed as well that he has failed to secure a commission in the guards.
他屈服于他所谓的“生殖器的邪恶恶魔”。那确实是个邪恶恶魔，是的。他一直把自己关在房间里，你知道，在从淋病中恢复过来。现在他出来了，并且决心不再得病。所以当他出城鬼混时，他穿着他所谓的“盔甲”，也就是一种原始的安全套。是的。他在圣詹姆斯公园游荡，在干草市场可以勾搭到所有最迷人的妓女。有一次，他甚至把一个从干草市场带出来的女孩带到了威斯敏斯特大桥，仅仅是为了体验在泰晤士河滔滔河水下与她发生性行为的刺激。他说这“让我觉得很有趣”。所以他……很容易满足。嗯，我觉得一个喜欢用各种奇怪的方式来为自己的享乐增添情趣的男人……但这正是他不快乐的指标。他不仅因为自己陷入了他所谓的放荡而感到沮丧——我的意思是，他对自己的所作所为感觉并不好。他还在做，但感觉并不好。而且他还因为未能获得近卫军的军官委任而沮丧。
You know, he's not going to be tashing around in a red coat. And this means essentially that he is going to have to pursue a career in the law, which is what his father had always intended for him. And so he's highly suspicious that it is Lord Affleck, his father, who has pulled strings and denied him his chance to be in the guards. Right. And this is what sets the scene for the meeting with Samuel Johnson that we described at the beginning of the last episode. And, you know, this is the moment to which he's looked forward for so long.
你知道，他没法穿着红外套四处招摇了。这意味着他基本上将不得不去从事法律职业，而这正是他父亲一直为他安排的。因此，他高度怀疑正是他的父亲奥斯勒克勋爵在背后操纵，剥夺了他加入近卫军的机会。没错。而这就为我们在上一集开头描述的与塞缪尔·约翰逊的会面拉开了序幕。你知道，这是他期待已久的时刻，
But actually that foul fiend is still on his shoulder, right? Because just after he meets Johnson, his back out on. the streets and he's forgotten his armour. Paul from Boswell. It doesn't stop him. So, you know, he's playing riskily. Yeah. But it's clear, I think, that despite this, or maybe because of this, he's still very keen
但实际上那个邪恶恶魔仍然压在他的肩头，对吧？因为就在他见到约翰逊之后，他又回到了街上，而且他忘带盔甲了。可怜的博斯韦尔。但这并没有阻止他。所以，你知道，他在进行危险的冒险。是的。但我想很明显，尽管如此，或者也许正因为如此，他仍然非常渴望
to have Johnson's advice, his friendship, and above all, I think, his moral guidance. And although Johnson had been quite bearish with him, you know, he had been very rude about him being Scottish and so on. Yeah. Boswell plucks up courage and one week after his first meeting with Johnson, he goes to meet the great man in his chambers in a temple lane. And Boswell has a brilliant description of how Johnson received him. He received me very courteously, but it must be confessed that his apartment and furniture and morning dress was sufficiently uncouth. His brown suit of clothes looked very rusty.
得到约翰逊的建议、友谊，最重要的是，我认为是他的道德指导。尽管约翰逊对他相当粗暴，你知道的，他对博斯韦尔是苏格兰人一事非常粗鲁等等。是的。博斯韦尔鼓起勇气，在与约翰逊第一次见面的一周后，前往圣殿巷的寓所拜访这位伟人。博斯韦尔对约翰逊是如何接待他的有着精彩的描述：“他非常客气地接待了我，但必须承认，他的公寓、家具和晨服都足够粗陋。他那套棕色的衣服看起来非常陈旧。
He had on a little old shriveled and powdered wig, which was too small for his head. His shirt neck and knees of his breeches were loose His black worsted stockings ill-drawn up And he had a pair of unbuckled shoes by way of slippers But all these slovenly particularities were forgotten The moment that he began to talk So he dresses like Boris Johnson Actually sort of slovenly
他戴着一顶旧而干瘪的小发套，对他来说太小了。他的衬衫领口和马裤的膝盖处都是松垮的。他的黑色精纺羊毛袜没穿好，往下搭拉着。他踩着一双没有鞋扣的鞋子当作拖鞋。但所有这些邋遢的细节都被遗忘了，就在他开口说话的那一刻。”所以他的穿着打扮就像鲍里斯·约翰逊。实际上有点邋遢。
Almost ostentatiously slovenly But actually the more that Boswell goes to see him The slovenliness is overlooked He really falls in love with Johnson, doesn't he? Don't you think? I mean, he was primed for it before he went, but he becomes, you know, he starts to think actually Johnson really does like me. He's giving him maybe a bit less, maybe some of the barbs about Scotland have a little less poison than they did beforehand. I mean, the barbs continue. I think what Boswell does feel that Johnson likes him,
几乎是炫耀般的邋遢。但实际上，随着博斯韦尔越来越频繁地去拜访他，那种邋遢就被忽略了。他真的爱上了约翰逊，不是吗？你不觉得吗？我的意思是，他去之前就已经做好了心理准备，但他开始认为，实际上约翰逊确实挺喜欢我的。他对他的评价也许少了一点，也许关于苏格兰的一些尖刻言论没有之前那么充满恶意了。我的意思是，那些尖刻言论还在继续。我认为博斯韦尔确实感觉到约翰逊喜欢他，
and India calls Johnson will say this specifically, but I think there's the kind of the magic of Johnson's conversation. And Boswell finds in Johnson a kind of a great champion of conversation. It's like watching a tremendous sports star taking on all comers. And that I think is a crucial part of the thrill of it for Boswell. So he gives a couple of instances of Johnson's conversation in the kind of the early meetings, which illustrates this. So on one occasion, there's a critic who's written a bad review of a tragedy. And the critic is saying, well, actually, maybe I shouldn't have given the bad review, because who am I? I can't write a tragedy. And Johnson's very contemptuous of this. Why, I know, sir, this is not just reasoning. You may abuse a tragedy, though you cannot
而且正如印度所说，约翰逊会具体说明这一点，但我认为有一种约翰逊谈话的魔力。博斯韦尔在约翰逊身上发现了一种伟大的谈话冠军。这就像看着一个巨大的体育明星迎战所有挑战者。我认为这正是博斯韦尔感到刺激的关键部分。因此，他在早期的几次会面中举出了几个约翰逊谈话的例子，说明了这一点。有一次，有个批评家对一首悲剧写了糟糕的评论。而这个批评家说，好吧，其实我不该写这个糟糕的评论，因为我是谁呢？我也写不出悲剧。约翰逊对此极其蔑视。“为什么，我知道，先生，这不是正确的推理。你即使写不出一首悲剧，也可以痛骂它。
write one. You may scold a carpenter who has made you a bad table, though you cannot make a table. It is not your trade to make tables. It's not wrong. That's the critic flattened. And then there's another Scott, not Boswell, who is talking to Johnson, but Boswell is listening. And Scott insists that his country had many noble prospects. And Johnson comes back, so let me tell you, the noblest prospect which a Scotchman ever sees, is the high road that leads him to England. Boswell, right. This unexpected and pointed Sally produced a roar of applause.
你即使不会做桌子，也可以训斥一个给你做了坏桌子的木匠。做桌子不是你的行当。”这话没错。那个批评家被驳得体无完肤。然后还有另一个苏格兰人，不是博斯韦尔，在和约翰逊说话，但博斯韦尔在听。那个苏格兰人坚称他的祖国有很多崇高的前景。约翰逊反驳道：“那么我告诉你，苏格兰人见过的最崇高的前景，就是通往英格兰的大道。”博斯韦尔写道。这个意料之外、一针见血的俏皮话引发了一片雷鸣般的掌声。
This is tremendous banter. Massive banter. But this makes the fact that Johnson seems to like Boswell, all the more kind of glorious for Boswell. And Johnson starts to give him exactly the kind of comfort and moral guidance that Boswell had been looking for. So Boswell gets evicted from his rooms in Downing, street because he's been having a late-night party. And Johnson, unlike, you know, Lord Affleck would have
这真是绝妙的打趣。极大的打趣。但这让约翰逊似乎喜欢博斯韦尔这一事实，对博斯韦尔来说更加光荣。约翰逊开始给他提供正是博斯韦尔一直在寻找的那种安慰和道德指导。因此博斯韦尔被赶出了他在唐宁街的房间，因为他在那里开深夜派对。而约翰逊——不像奥斯勒克勋爵那样
torn his head off at this. Johnson doesn't. He says, consider, sir, how insignificant this will appear a 12-month hence. It's good advice. I mean, it's such good advice. It's such good advice. And then when in due course, Lord Affleck says, you are going to become a lawyer to his son. And Boswell says, okay, but maybe I could I go and study law in Utrecht in the low countries? And Lord Affleck says, yes, okay, I'll pay you to do that. And Boswell's kind of initially happy about this, but then he starts to worry. Isn't Echran to be very boring? He's going to have to leave London. He's going to have to leave Dr. Johnson. And he really becomes quite depressed about this. And Johnson recognises it. And because he knows that the two of them are going to have to part,
会把他的头扭下来。约翰逊没有这样做。他说：“想一想，先生，从现在起一年后，这显得多么无足轻重。”这是个好建议。我的意思是，这真是个好建议。这真是个好建议。随后，当奥斯勒克勋爵对他的儿子说“你要去当律师”时，博斯韦尔说“好吧，但也许我可以去低地国家的乌得勒支学法律呢？”奥斯勒克勋爵说“好吧，我出钱让你去。”博斯韦尔起初对此感到高兴，但他随后开始担心。乌得勒支不是会很无聊吗？他将不得不离开伦敦。他将不得不离开约翰逊博士。他为此真的变得相当沮丧。而约翰逊意识到了这一点。因为他知道他们两人将不得不分离，
he suggests a trip to Greenwich, so downriver from London. And they take a boat and they talk and they talk and they talk. Boswell's entire description of this day is wonderful, but just to give some highlights from it. So they're talking about whether learning matters. Boswell says, of course, everybody should learn. And Johnson says, well, there are lots of people who don't need learning for their job. I don't think that it matters to them at all. And he then turns to the boy who is rowing them in the boat. And he says, this boy rows us as well without learning as if he could sing the song of Orpheus to the Argonauts who were the first sailors.
他建议去格林威治旅行，也就是顺着伦敦向下游去。他们坐船聊天，聊个不停。博斯韦尔对这一天的全部描述都妙趣横生，这里只举出其中的一些亮点。他们在谈论学习是否重要。博斯韦尔说，当然，每个人都应该学习。约翰逊说，嗯，有很多人他们的工作不需要学习。我认为这根本不重要。然后他转向那个在船上划船的男孩，说道：“这个男孩没有学问，但船划得和能对雅典娜的水手、第一批水手唱奥菲斯之歌的人一样好。”
So he doesn't need to know about Jason and the Argonauts to row the boat. He then called to the boy, what would you give my lad to know about the Argonauts? Sir, said the boy, I would give what I have. Now, that's contradicting what Johnson had argued. But Boswell says Johnson was much pleased with his answer, and we gave him a double fare. So Johnson loves the fact that there is an appetite for learning about Greek mythology, even on the taxi boats of London. And what do they make of Greenwich?
所以他不需要了解伊阿宋和阿尔戈英雄就能划船。他接着对那个男孩喊道：“小伙子，为了了解阿尔戈英雄，你愿意付出什么？”男孩说：“先生，我愿意付出我所有的一切。”这与约翰逊之前的论点相矛盾。但博斯韦尔说，约翰逊对他的回答非常高兴，我们给了他双倍的船资。所以约翰逊很高兴人们有强烈的愿望去了解希腊神话，即使是在伦敦的出租小船上。他们对格林威治有什么看法？
They're actually slightly underwhelmed. Well, no, they kind of walk in the park and they both agree that it's very beautiful. When Johnson asked Boswell, you know, is it not very fine? Boswell answers, yes, sir, but not equal of Fleet Street. And Johnson says, you are right, sir. Johnson much prefers a bustling thoroughfare to a kind of, you know, a load of trees. And they return so late in the evening. They've been having such a great time that Boswell shivers the whole way because, you know, it's quite cold.
其实他们稍微有些失望。嗯，不，他们去公园散步，都一致认为那里非常美丽。当约翰逊问博斯韦尔“这不是很好吗？”博斯韦尔回答说：“是的，先生，但比不上弗利特街。”约翰逊说：“你说得对，先生。”约翰逊比起一堆树木来，明显更喜欢熙熙攘攘的大街。他们很晚才回到傍晚。他们玩得太开心了，以至于博斯韦尔一路上都在发抖，因为，你知道，天气相当冷。
Johnson, whose robust frame was not in the least affected by the cold, scolded me as if my shivering had been a paltry of feminacy. They arrived back in London, they head to the Strand, and they end up at the Turks head coffee house. They're still talking, and by now Boswell is feeling that he's ready to share all kinds of intimacies and confidences with Johnson, and so he tells him about the castle at Affleck, and Johnson says one day that he will see it.
约翰逊那健壮的体格丝毫不受寒冷的影响，却责备我，仿佛我的颤抖是一种卑微的女性气质。他们回到伦敦，前往斯特兰德大街，最后来到了土头咖啡馆。他们还在谈论，此时博斯韦尔觉得他准备好与约翰逊分享各种亲密和秘密了，于是他向他讲述了奥斯勒克城堡，约翰逊说总有一天他会去看看。
And they then talk more and more about, you know, the looming departure. Boswell is clearly very, very unhappy to be leaving. He's nervous. And Johnson says, I must see the out of England. I will accompany you to Harwich. And Harwich is where he'll be sailing up to the low countries. And this was, as Boswell absolutely recognized, a signal mark of honour. This is not the kind of thing Johnson would normally have done.
接着他们越来越多地谈论即将到来的离别。博斯韦尔显然非常非常不高兴离开。他很紧张。约翰逊说：“我必须送你离开英格兰。我将陪你到哈维奇。”哈维奇是开往低地国家的航船起航的地方。正如博斯韦尔完全意识到的那样，这是一个崇高的荣誉。这不是约翰逊通常会做的事情。
And Boswell writes, it filled me with gratitude. And there's so, Boswell, and vanity. No, that's fair, though. I mean, it's so true, though, isn't it? No one would go to Harwich voluntarily. I mean, it is a proper honour from Johnson. But Boswell is still a bit gloomy, isn't he, about going? And then it's nice because Johnson, who suffers himself from depression and melancholy, can see this and sort of is sympathetic.
博斯韦尔写道：“这让我充满了感激之情。”太博斯韦尔了，还有虚荣。不，不过这很公平。我的意思是，这太真实了，不是吗？没有人会自愿去哈维奇。我的意思是，这是约翰逊给予的真正的荣誉。但博斯韦尔对离开仍然有点闷闷不乐，不是吗？然后挺好的是，约翰逊自己也饱受抑郁和忧郁之苦，他看出了这一点，并表现出同情。
Yes, he roused me by manly and spirited conversation, which I think is great. I mean, who wouldn't respond to some manly and spirited conversation when a bit depressed? Yeah. And they head off in the coach from London towards Harwich. And the whole way Johnson is, you know, very effectively rallying his spirits. And they stop the night at Colchester, you know, having a meal, and they've got candles flickering in front of them on their table. And there's a moth. And the moth flutters around the candle and burns itself.
是的，他用男子汉气概和充满生气的谈话唤醒了我，我认为这太棒了。我的意思是，当有点沮丧时，谁不会对那些充满男子气概和生气的谈话作出反应呢？是的。他们坐上从伦敦前往哈维奇的马车，一路上约翰逊都非常有效地重振他的精神。他们在科尔切斯特过夜，吃着饭，桌子前面闪烁着蜡烛。有一只飞蛾。飞蛾绕着蜡烛飞舞，把自己烧伤了。
And Boswell writes about this, Johnson laid hold of this little incident to admonish me, saying, with a sly look and in a solemn but a quiet tone, that creature was its own tormentor, and I believe its name. was Boswell. Yeah, what did Boswell make of this? He liked it. He did like it. I mean, that's why he recorded it. And the next day they arrive at Harwich and they load Boswell's luggage onto the packet boat. And then they go to the church and Johnson admonishes him to pray.
博斯韦尔对此有详细的记录：约翰逊抓住这个小插曲来告诫我，他带着狡黠的表情，用庄严而平静的语气说：“那个家伙简直是自作自受，我想他的名字就叫博斯韦尔。”是的，博斯韦尔对这件事怎么看？他很喜欢。他确实很喜欢。我的意思是，这就是他把它记录下来的原因。第二天，他们抵达哈威奇，把博斯韦尔的行李搬上邮船。然后他们去了教堂，约翰逊劝导他祈祷。
Now that you are going to leave your native country, recommend yourself to the production of your creator and redeemer. And then that done, they head to the beach. They embrace and they part. I hope, sir, Boswell said, you will not forget me in my absence. No, sir, Johnson replied. it is more likely that you should forget me than that I should forget you. And Boswell boards the ship and it pulls out of the harbour and it sets sails for the low countries. And Johnson is still there watching.
既然你即将离开祖国，就将自己托付给你的造物主和救赎主的庇护吧。这一切做完后，他们前往海滩。他们拥抱并告别。“先生，我希望，”博斯韦尔说，“你在我不在的时候不要忘记我。”“不，先生，”约翰逊回答，“比起我忘记你，你更有可能会忘记我。”博斯韦尔登上了船，船缓缓驶出港口，扬帆驶向低地国家。而约翰逊依然站在那里注视着。
And Boswell writes, as the vessel put out to sea, I kept my eyes upon him for a considerable time, while he remained rolling his majestic frame in his usual manner. And at last, I perceived him walk back into the town and he disappeared. Oh, it's very sweet. So will they ever see each other again? That's the question on everybody's minds, because we're ending on a tremendous cliffhanger. Boswell has gone off to Holland. Is he going to turn into a Dutchman? Will he return and rekindle his relationship with Samuel Johnson? We'll find out after the break. This episode is brought to you by Claude, by Anthropic. Now history lives in the contradictions. Yeah, I've always been fascinated by the great mysteries of history. Like what happens? to the Maya civilization of Central America? Why were all those great cities deserted? But Tom, there's one mystery that's always fascinated you, isn't there? Yes, Dominic, I've always been fascinated by the question of how humans came to make and use fire. How did that originate?
博斯韦尔写道：“当船驶向大海时，我久久地注视着他，而他则像往常一样晃动着他那雄伟的身躯。最后，我看到他走回镇上，消失不见了。”哦，这太美好了。那么他们以后还会再见面吗？这是每个人心中的疑问，因为我们的故事在一个巨大的悬念中结束了。博斯韦尔去了荷兰。他会变成一个荷兰人吗？他会回来并重燃他与塞缪尔·约翰逊的关系吗？我们将在中场休息后揭晓。本集由 Anthropic 的 Claude 赞助播出。历史往往存在于矛盾之中。是的，我一直对历史上的巨大谜团着迷。比如中美洲的玛雅文明发生了什么？为什么那些伟大的城市都被废弃了？但是，汤姆，有一个谜团一直让你着迷，对吧？是的，多米尼克，我一直对人类是如何开始制造和使用火的问题着迷。那是怎么起源的？
And a tremendous discovery was announced just last year that the place where it seems fire was invented was Suffolk. Well, do you know, one of the things that makes history so fascinating is the kind of back and forth between sources to try and explain these great mysteries. And you know what's built for that kind of thinking? Claude is built for that way of thinking. It doesn't smooth things over. It helps you dig into the disagreement to reveal something new. An Anthropic just committed to not running adverts in Claude.
就在去年，一项重大的发现被公布，火似乎被发明的地点是萨福克。你知道吗，让历史如此迷人的原因之一，就是在各种资料之间进行来回对照，试图解释这些巨大的谜团。你知道什么正是为此类思考而构建的吗？Claude 就是为这种思考方式而构建的。它不会粉饰太平。它能帮你深入探讨分歧，从而揭示出新的东西。Anthropic 刚刚承诺不在 Claude 中投放广告。
So your thinking stays yours. Try Claude for free at clod. To some, he is the revolutionary hero who restored China to its rightful place on the global stage. To others, he's a brutal despot, accused of presiding over more civilian deaths than either Stalin or Hitler. Mao Zedong has one of the most recognizable faces in the world, yet he started life as a rural boy in a muddy provincial village. A rebel son who hated his father, survived a 6,000 mile walk across China and rose to become a figure. of titanic proportions. From Empire, the Goalhanger World History Show, I'm Anita Arnan.
所以你的思维依然是你自己的。免费体验 Claude，网址为 clod.com。在有些人看来，他是将中国恢复其在世界舞台上应有地位的革命英雄。但在另一些人看来，他是一个残暴的独裁者，被指控导致比斯大林或希特勒还要多的平民死亡。毛泽东拥有世界上辨识度最高的面孔之一，然而他最初只是泥泞的省级村庄里的一个农村男孩。一个痛恨父亲的叛逆之子，在全中国进行了六千英里的长征，最终崛起为一个具有泰坦般伟大的历史人物。欢迎收听由 Goalhanger 世界历史秀制作的《帝国》，我是主持人阿妮塔·阿南德。
And I'm William Durember. In this six-part series, we're joined by world-renowned expert Rana Mitter to explore the life of the father of communist China, Mao Zedong. We'll track his rise from a bookstore owner to a guerrilla commander and will witness his ruthless elimination to secure total power. We'll explore their greatest famine in human history, a catastrophe where Mao himself predicted that half of China may well have to die. And we'll descend into the dark experiment of the cultural revolution. A time when ancient temples were burnt, children denounced their parents and a nation worshipped a mango as a sacred relic.
我是威廉·达林姆贝尔。在这部共六集的系列节目中，我们邀请了世界著名的专家 Rana Mitter，一同探索中国共产主义之父毛泽东的一生。我们将追溯他从一个书店老板到游击队指挥官的崛起历程，并见证他为了巩固绝对权力而进行的无情清洗。我们将探讨人类历史上最严重的大饥荒，那是一场灾难，毛泽东本人曾预测中国可能有一半的人不得不死。我们还将深入了解文化大革命的黑暗实验。那是一个古老寺庙被烧毁、孩子们公开谴责父母、整个国家将一颗芒果视为神圣圣物的时代。
And we'll play a clip from the series at the end of this episode for you to listen to. At every hour, the bells of the great tower played a dreary psalm tune. A deep melancholy seized upon me. I groaned at the idea of living all winter and so shocking a place. I thought myself old and wretched and forlorn. So that could be any number of travellers who've spent time in the Netherlands. It's actually James Boswell and he's writing to Samuel Johnson on the 23rd of September 1763. And Boswell basically finds Utrecht, just as he had feared, unbelievably dreary and boring.
在本集结束时，我们将为您播放该系列节目的一个精彩片段供您收听。每到整点，大钟楼的钟声就会奏出一曲沉闷的赞美诗调子。一种深沉的忧郁攫住了我。一想到要在如此令人震惊的地方度过整个冬天，我就发出痛苦的呻吟。我觉得自己又老、又可怜、又无依无靠。所以，这可能适用于任何在荷兰度过时光的旅行者。这其实是詹姆斯·博斯韦尔，他在1763年9月23日写信给塞缪尔·约翰逊。博斯韦尔基本上发现乌得勒支正如他所担心的那样，令人难以置信的沉闷和无聊。
Yeah, he hates it. He absolutely hates him incredibly dull. There's nothing else to do except study law. Yeah. And he can't even go out and haunt the streets because he has made a solemn vow that he's going to behave as well as possible in emulation of his new hero, Samuel Johnson. And to stop being, as he puts it, a frivolous and ludicrous fellow. And so he's written up an inviolable plan to be read over frequently in which he writes, for some years past you have been idle, dissipated, absurd and unhappy.
是的，他讨厌这个地方。他绝对讨厌这里，觉得这里无聊透顶。除了学习法律，别无他事可做。是的。而且他甚至不能出去在街上闲逛，因为他已经庄严发誓，要效仿他的新偶像塞缪尔·约翰逊，尽可能表现得体。不再做一个他所说的“轻浮滑稽的家伙”。因此，他写下了一份不可违背的计划，并经常拿出来阅读。他在计划中写道：“在过去的几年里，你一直游手好闲、放浪形骸、荒谬绝伦且郁郁不得志。”
Let those years be thought of no more. You are now determined to form yourself into a man. Oh, well, that's inspiring. No, but it isn't because it's terrible. You know, he's said he's bored, he's lonely, it just, you know, he's oppressed by religious doubts and fear of death. And Johnson isn't on hand. In fact, there are no great men on hand, and he just has a terrible time.
让那些岁月不再被记起吧。你现在决心将自己塑造为一个真正的男子汉。哦，这真激励人心。不，其实一点也不，因为这太糟糕了。你知道的，他说自己很无聊，很孤独，你知道的，他被宗教疑虑和对死亡的恐惧所压垮。而且约翰逊不在身边。事实上，周围也没有什么伟人，他只是度过了一段糟糕的时光。
But then by the summer of 1764, his year of legal studies is over, and things begin to perk up. And because he's completed his law degree, and Lord Affleck is very pleased by this, you know, maybe a little bit surprised. Lord Affleck says, look, before you come back, go on a tour of the various courts of Germany, and I will pay for it. And Boswell, you know, doesn't need to be told second time. He's straight off. He loves traveling. So he sets off to Germany. This is a time, you know, Germany isn't a unified country. It's full of mad little courts all over the place. And Boswell is a great hit. We've said, you know, he's great fun. People like him. And hanging out in courts, kind of meeting princes in opulent surroundings, this is exactly the kind of thing Boswell loves. And the princes in their courtiers all think he's great as well. You know, he's fun. He dresses well. He's amusing. He's got just the right degree of interest in philosophy. So just enough to show the Germans that he's a serious person, but not so much that he becomes a bit boring. The only disappointment in Germany is he doesn't get to meet Frederick the Great. He hangs around in Berlin for a month.
但到了1764年夏天，他一年的法律学习结束了，情况开始好转。因为他完成了法学学位，阿瑟克勋爵对此非常高兴，你知道的，也许还有点吃惊。阿瑟克勋爵说：“听着，在你回来之前，去考察一下德国的各大法院吧，费用我来出。”博斯韦尔呢，根本不用提醒第二遍。他立刻就出发了。他热爱旅行。于是他动身前往德国。这是一个特殊的时期，你知道的，当时的德国并不是一个统一的国家。到处都是疯狂的小公国，而博斯韦尔大受欢迎。我们说过，你知道的，他很有趣。人们都很喜欢他。在宫廷里闲逛，在富丽堂皇的环境中与王子们会面，这正是博斯韦尔最喜欢的事情。王子们和他们的朝臣们也觉得他非常棒。你知道的，他很有趣。他穿着得体。他很逗趣。他对哲学有着恰到好处的兴趣，刚好向德国人展示他是一个严肃的人，但又不会严肃到让人感到无聊的程度。他在德国唯一的遗憾就是没能见到腓特烈大帝。他在柏林逗留了一个月。
And he ends up so desperate that he takes out his airshar bonnet, which he's brought with him. And he puts it on his head and kind of stands in a prominent place when Frederick the Great is on parade, hoping that Frederick the Great will see it and take an interest in it. And Frederick does notice it, but doesn't like it. Surely not tall enough for Frederick the Great and not sufficiently interested in military parades. I think that we've said that Boswell's face is not that of a man who's interested in military parades. No, definitely not. Which is also another reason why it's very lucky for him. I think he didn't get into the guards. Yeah, definitely. Hoplessly ill-suited to it. Once he's finished faffing around in Germany, you might think, well,
他最后甚至绝望到拿出了自己带来的艾尔郡无边便帽。他把它戴在头上，站在一个显眼的地方，当时腓特烈大帝正在检阅部队，希望腓特烈大帝能看到它并对它产生兴趣。腓特烈确实注意到了它，但并不喜欢。对于腓特烈大帝来说，这肯定不够高大上，而且他对军事阅兵也不够感兴趣。我想我们已经说过，博斯韦尔的脸并不是那种对军事阅兵感兴趣的人的脸。不，绝对不是。这也是为什么说他没有进入近卫军对他来说非常幸运的另一个原因。是的，绝对是的。他完全不适合做这个。一旦他在德国胡闹够了，你可能会觉得，嗯，
it's time to go back to Scotland or indeed to London to see. see Dr. Johnson again, but no. He goes on, doesn't he, to Switzerland, because now he's in his sleb hunting vein, and there's, well, there's a couple of celebrities in particular. And one of these people is one of the worst men who's ever lived. Yeah, it's Jean-Jacques Rousseau. John Jack Rousseau is the first of these two celebrities that Boswell's going to meet. Like Johnson, he's more than a celebrity. He's a great moralist, or at least. So it seems at this point, he's also a philosopher, he's a novelist. He has very novel views on sex, on religion, on society, particularly on education. He's very, very keen on the notion that
是时候回苏格兰了，或者回伦敦去再次拜访约翰逊博士了，但并没有。他接着去了瑞士，对吧？因为他现在正处于猎奇名人录的阶段，而且那里，嗯，有几位特别的名人。其中一个人是史上最糟糕的人之一。没错，就是让-雅克·卢梭。让-雅克·卢梭是博斯韦尔要见这两位名人中的第一位。就像约翰逊一样，他不仅仅是一个名人。他是一位伟大的道德家，至少在这个时候看来是这样的。他同时也是一位哲学家、小说家。他对性、宗教、社会，特别是对教育有着非常新颖的观点。他非常非常热衷于这样一个观念：
parents should take good care of their children and bring them up responsibly. And for all of these reasons, I think Boswell, as he had done when he arrived in London, is looking for someone who can provide him with moral guidance. And so he goes to the village where Rousseau is living, and he writes to him begging for a meeting. And Rousseau replies, I am ill in pain, really in no state to receive visits. Yeah, you'd expect that from him. And this would probably put most people off, but it doesn't put Boswell off. Yeah.
父母应该好好照顾他们的孩子，并负责任地把他们养大。出于所有这些原因，我认为博斯韦尔就像他刚到伦敦时一样，在寻找一个能为他提供道德指导的人。于是他来到了卢梭居住的村庄，并写信请求与他见面。卢梭回复道：“我生病了，浑身疼痛，实在不适合接待来访。”是的，你对他的回应意料之中。这可能会让大多数人打退堂鼓，但并没有吓退博斯韦尔。是的。
You know, he turns up at the door. Rousseau's housekeeper, who inevitably is also his mistress, in fact, has given him five children, comes down the stairs. She's a French woman called Therese Le Vasseur. Boswell absolutely charms her. Sweet talks her into allowing her in. He goes upstairs, and there is Rousseau sitting in the kitchen. and Rousseau is famously grouchy
你知道的，他直接敲响了房门。卢梭的女管家（不可避免地，她同时也是他的情妇，事实上，她已经为卢梭生了五个孩子）走下楼梯。她是一个名叫特蕾丝·勒瓦瑟的法国女人。博斯韦尔完全迷住了她。甜言蜜语说服她让自己进去。他走上楼去，只见卢梭正坐在厨房里。而卢梭出了名的脾气暴躁，
and he periodically tries to get rid of Boswell by saying that he needs to use his chamber pot but Boswell, oh, don't stand on ceremony with me go on, crack on, yeah, don't worry about me. But basically, Boswell is not remotely put off by Rousseau needing to use his chamber pot at all hangs around and Rousseau ends up being completely charmed by him.
他时不时地试图打发博斯韦尔走，说他需要用马桶。但博斯韦尔却说：“哦，别跟我客套啦，去吧，尽管去，是的，不用管我。”总之，博斯韦尔一点也没有因为卢梭需要用马桶而被吓退。他就在那儿磨蹭，最后卢梭彻底被他的魅力给迷住了。
And they do end up having a... series of really quite lengthy chats over the course of five days. And this for biographers of Rousseau is an incredible resource. So Peter Martin, who's written the definitive biography of Boswell, says that Boswell's account of Rousseau's speech is accepted as the most vivid known to exist. Well, Boswell, I mean, if he'd had a smartphone, he would so have recorded it all and put it on social media. And that's effectively what he's doing with, you know, he talks to Rousseau, he rushes back to his in, he writes it all up. And so there you have, what is the closest we will ever have to a recording of Rousseau's conversation. And Borswell is delirously
他们最终在五天的时间里进行了一系列……相当冗长的交谈。对于卢梭的传记作家来说，这可是一笔不可思议的宝贵财富。因此，撰写了博斯韦尔权威传记的彼得·马丁说，博斯韦尔对卢梭言论的记录被认为是现存最生动的记录。好吧，博斯韦尔，我的意思是，如果他当时有智能手机，他肯定会把这一切都录下来并发布到社交媒体上了。而这实际上就是他一直在做的事情，你知道的，他与卢梭交谈，然后冲回客栈，把这一切都写下来。所以你看，这就是我们所能拥有的最接近卢梭谈话录音的东西了。而博斯韦尔对此感到欣喜若狂。
happy about this. And again, there's this sense when he writes it up in his journal of kind of watching himself as the hero of his journal. So he writes, God, am I now then really the friend of Rousseau? I suppose the parcel of a young fellow saying, come Boswell, you'll dine with us today. No, gentlemen, excuse me, I'm engaged. I dine today with Rousseau. The sense of pride is so comical, but I think so engaging. And if there's one person, I mean, there's probably only one person who's even more famous than Rousseau among francophone philosophers and wits and sort of scholars and thinkers and whatnot. And that is, is Voltaire. Yeah. And once again, Boswell, I mean, we don't have the chamber pot trick, but Boswell basically talks himself into Voltaire's company, doesn't he? Yeah, so Voltaire's just down the road from Rousseau.
对此感到高兴。而且，当他在日记中记录这段经历时，那种感觉就像是在看着自己成为日记中的英雄。于是他写道：“天哪，我现在真的是卢梭的朋友了吗？我想象着一帮年轻人走过来对我说：‘来吧，博斯韦尔，今天和我们一起吃晚饭吧。’‘不，先生们，请原谅我，我有约了。我今天要和卢梭共进晚餐。’”这种骄傲感实在是滑稽可笑，但我觉得又非常迷人。如果在法语哲学家、机智之士、学者和思想家等等之中，有一个人（可能也只有一个人）甚至比卢梭还要出名，那就是伏尔泰。是的。而又一次，博斯韦尔——虽然我们没有用马桶的计谋，但博斯韦尔基本上凭三寸不烂之舌说服了伏尔泰与他交往，对吧？是的，所以伏尔泰就住在离卢梭不远的地方。
He's in Switzerland as well. And again, Boswell turns up, he's told no, Monsieur Voltaire doesn't want to see you, Boswell hangs around, eventually Voltaire comes down in his dressing gown. Boswell pounces on him. And again, Voltaire is kind of seduced by Boswell's charm. and again, Boswell writes it up in such a kind of entertainingly self-regarding way. Monsieur de Voltaire and I remained in the drawing room with a great Bible before us, and if ever two mortal men disputed with vehemence, we did.
他也住在瑞士。同样，博斯韦尔找上门去，结果被告知：“不，伏尔泰先生不想见你。”博斯韦尔就在那儿磨蹭，直到最后伏尔泰穿着晨衣走了下来。博斯韦尔立刻扑了上去。而且，伏尔泰再次被博斯韦尔的魅力所折服。博斯韦尔又一次以一种极其具有娱乐性、自我标榜的方式记录下了这段经历：“德·伏尔泰先生和我留在了客厅里，面前摆着一本厚厚的大圣经，如果有哪两个凡人曾经激烈争论过，那一定就是我们俩。”
Yes, upon that occasion, he was one individual and I another for a certain portion of time. There was a fair opposition between Voltaire and Boswell. It would be interesting to hear Voltaire's version. conversation to see if it was exactly the same. I mean, the context for this is that Volta is the most famous infidel in Europe. Right. And Boswell is turning up and casting himself as, you know, the person who's going to convert Rousseau back to orthodoxy and so on.
是的，在那次场合中，在一段时间里，他是一个独立的个体，而我是另一个。伏尔泰和博斯韦尔之间进行了一场公平的辩论。听听伏尔泰版本的对话会很有趣，看看它是否完全一样。我的意思是，这背后的背景是，伏尔泰是欧洲最著名的异教徒。没错。而博斯韦尔却找上门来，把自己塑造成那个要将卢梭重新皈依正统等等的人。
And again, I think it's so revealing about exactly why Boswell loves meeting these great men. It's not just about celebrity. It's about getting moral guidance of people who he recognizes are much profound, a much more brilliant thinkers than he is actually in his heart of hearts. So I think there is an element of self-mockery in that description of Voltaire and Boswell being intellectual equals. And while this has been going on, his father, Lord Affleck, has been pestering him saying, what on earth are you doing? You were meant to come home after you finished your studies and you trekked and you're going
再次说明，我觉得这非常深刻地揭示了为什么博斯韦尔如此喜欢结识这些伟人。这不仅仅是为了追逐名气。这是为了从那些他内心深处承认比自己深刻得多、聪明得多的人那里获得道德指导。所以我认为，在对伏尔泰和博斯韦尔是势均力敌的知识分子的描述中，其实带有一点自我嘲讽的成分。正当这一切发生的时候，他的父亲阿瑟克勋爵一直在纠缠他，质问他：“你到底在搞什么鬼？你本该在结束学业和乌得勒支之旅后就回家，而你却越走越远，离苏格兰越来越远，而不是越来越近。”
further and further away from Scotland, not towards it. And Voltaire and Rousseau, I mean, these are not the kind of people that a Scottish Presbyterian wig would in any way approve of. And so he is absolutely saying to Boswell, come home now, and Boswell predictably completely ignores it, because there is one further celebrity he's going to meet, and this is going to be the most incredible drama of all. So from Switzerland, Boswell goes to Italy, where he, as we will see, misbehaves himself very badly. and then from Italy he set sail for Corsica. And almost everybody tells him you are mad to be going there. So the Corsicans are in the throes of an independent struggle against Genoa, who is the imperial mistress.
伏尔泰和卢梭，我的意思是，这些根本不是苏格兰长老会辉格党人所能赞同的那类人。因此，他绝对是在对博斯韦尔说：“马上回家。”而博斯韦尔不出所料地完全无视了这一点，因为他还要去见最后一位名人，这将是所有戏剧性事件中最不可思议的一幕。于是，从瑞士出发，博斯韦尔前往意大利，正如我们所见，在那里他表现得非常糟糕。接着，从意大利出发，他扬帆起航前往科西嘉岛。几乎所有人都告诉他：“你疯了，才会去那种地方。”因为科西嘉人正处于反抗热那亚（帝国的宗主国）独立斗争的水深火热之中。
So there's lots of guns going off all over the place. And that's what Corsica's like anyway. People are always firing guns in Corsica, even if they're not in a war. It's just a very, very violent place. And on the crossing, there are kind of Corsican sailors, and they tell Boswell, Any attempt to debauch a Corsican woman will result in instant death. So this is something that Boswell, to give him credit. That's bad news for Boswell.
所以到处都有枪声在响。而且科西嘉本来就是这个样子的。科西嘉人总是随时随地在开枪，哪怕他们不在打仗。这只是一个非常非常暴力的地方。在航渡的船上，有一些科西嘉水手，他们告诉博斯韦尔：“任何企图玷污科西嘉女人的行为都将招致即刻的死亡。”所以这是博斯韦尔（平心而论）注意到的事情。这对博斯韦尔来说是个坏消息。
He does take on board. So he lands. He knows that if he even so much as looks as a woman, he's going to get killed. So that's alarming. And then he has to make a very perilous journey across wild, mountainous, rocky country to join the freedom fighters. But Boswell absolutely loves it. He admires the primitive character of the Corsicans,
他确实把这话听进去了。所以他登陆了。他知道，哪怕自己只是多看一个女人一眼，都会被杀掉。所以这很令人担忧。然后，他必须踏上一段极其危险的旅程，穿过荒凉、多山、崎岖的乡间去加入自由战士。但博斯韦尔非常喜欢这样。他钦佩科西嘉人原始的性格，
which he identifies with the virtue of the ancient Greeks and Romans. And the chief object of this kind of hero worship of the Corsicans is the general who is leading the Corsican fight for independence. And this is Pascuali Paoli. So we talked about him in our episode about the young Napoleon. So back in the days when Napoleon had a Corsican sort of Genoese-style accent, he was greatly enamored of this guy, Pauly, who left a massive shadow not just over Corsica, But actually over Europe, he was the kind of Che Guevara, the romantic folk hero of the late 18th century, wasn't he?
他将这种性格与古希腊人和古罗马人的美德联系在一起。而他对科西嘉人这种英雄崇拜的主要对象，是一位领导科西嘉独立斗争的将军。这就是帕斯夸莱·帕奥里。我们在关于年轻拿破仑的那集节目中谈到过他。所以，早在拿破仑还带着一种科西嘉热那亚口音的时候，他就非常迷恋这个叫帕奥里的家伙，帕奥里不仅在科西嘉留下了巨大的阴影，实际上还在整个欧洲留下了巨大的影响。他是18世纪晚期的切·格瓦拉，浪漫的民间英雄，不是吗？
Completely. He is possibly the kind of the most admired political figure in Europe in this stretch of the 18th century. And Bolswell plays a key role in promoting him as that, because Boswell thinks Powley is amazing. And actually he hero worships Pauli even more than he hero worships Johnson. because he associates Paoli again with kind of ancient history. He sees him as someone stepped from the pages of Plutarch or something. And he describes Paoli, he's a tall, strong and well-made of a fair complexion, a sensible, free and open countenance and a manly and noble carriage.
完全是的。他可能是18世纪这一时期欧洲最受崇拜的政治人物。而博斯韦尔在将他推崇为这样的人物方面发挥了关键作用，因为博斯韦尔认为帕奥里太了不起了。事实上，他对帕奥里的英雄崇拜甚至超过了他对约翰逊的英雄崇拜。因为他再次将帕奥里与古代历史联系起来。他把帕奥里看作是从普鲁塔克等人的书页中走出来的人物。他这样描述帕奥里：他身材高大、强壮、体魄匀称，肤色白皙，面容明智、自由而坦率，举止刚毅而高贵。
This is a man who is fighting for freedom, who's laid his life on the line, and Boswell is all over this. Now, Paoli is completely bewildered by Boswell. Boswell is the first hero worshipper that Powley has met. And he can't fathom why Boswell has turned up. But as with Rousseau, as with Voltaire, his suspicions are gradually melted by Boswell's charm. And before long, as ever, Boswell is getting on with Pauli tremendously well. And Boswell stays with Powley for two months.
这是一个为自由而战、将生命押在赌注上的人，而博斯韦尔对这一切赞不绝口。现在，帕奥里对博斯韦尔感到十分困惑。博斯韦尔是帕奥里见过的第一个英雄崇拜者。他搞不懂博斯韦尔为什么会突然出现。但就像对待卢梭和伏尔泰一样，他的疑虑逐渐被博斯韦尔的魅力所融化。不久之后，一如既往地，博斯韦尔与帕奥里的关系好得不得了。博斯韦尔在帕奥里那里住了两个月。
And as they part, after this two months stay, Paoli takes him by the hand and shakes it. as Paoli says, as a friend. Oh, Boswell couldn't be more delighted at this. I dare not transcribe from my private notes the feelings which I had at this interview. I should perhaps appear too enthusiastic. So if Boswell is nervous about seeming too enthusiastic, I mean, he must be about to explode. And so he returns to Italy absolutely a glow with zeal for the course of. cause. And I would say that Boswell is probably the first in a long line of Europeans who
在他们离别之际，在这两个月的逗留之后，帕奥里拉起他的手并握了握，正如帕奥里所说，是作为朋友。哦，博斯韦尔对此感到高兴极了。我不敢从我的私人笔记中抄录我在这次会面时的感受。我可能会显得过于热情。所以，如果博斯韦尔连表现得过于热情都感到紧张的话，我的意思是，他当时一定快要兴奋得爆炸了。因此，他满怀着对这项事业的热情，容光焕发地回到了意大利。我要说的是，博斯韦尔可能是长长的欧洲人名单中的第一个，他们
travel to the scene of a freedom fight and come back absolutely enamoured with it. You said he's like Che Guevara. I mean, Boswell would absolutely have put up a Che Guevara poster. That's what he's all about. But actually, I mean, he goes much further than that. So he's, while again, this is quite student on a gap yearish, he returns from the island with a full outfit of Corsican clothes. And Pauley has given him a pair of pistols, so he's got those as well. He must look absolutely ridiculous walking around London. These Corscan trousers wave with his pistols.
前往自由之战的现场，然后带着绝对的迷恋回来。你说他就像切·格瓦拉。我的意思是，博斯韦尔绝对会贴一张切·格瓦拉的海报。他就是这样的人。但事实上，我的意思是，他走得更远。所以，虽然这再次表现得像是一个处于间隔年的学生，但他带着一整套科西嘉服装从岛上回来了。帕奥里还送了他一对双枪，所以他也有了这些。他走在伦敦街头时，看上去一定荒谬绝伦。穿着科西嘉长裤，挥舞着手枪。
Well, we will see. He does unfurl his Corsican costume when he's back in England in due course. When he's returned from Corsca on the continent, he starts writing unsigned letters to English newspapers, talking about Boswell in the third person, hinting that he's been to Corsica on a kind of secret mission on behalf of the British government. and his aim in doing this is to whip up interest in Britain, on behalf of course, and independence, to try and pressure the British government to swing behind Powley, you know, to kind of back him.
嗯，我们拭目以待。他在回到英国后，适时地展示了他的科西嘉服装。当他从大陆的科西嘉返回时，他开始向英国报纸写匿名信，在信中用第三人称谈论博斯韦尔，暗示他是代表英国政府去科西嘉执行某种秘密任务的。他这样做的目的是为了在英国激起人们对科西嘉独立的兴趣，试图向英国政府施压，使其支持帕奥里，你知道的，也就是某种程度上支持他。
It's a bit like, I suppose, you know, people in America trying to get Trump to back Zelensky. It's that kind of thing. But also, of course, it's always to a degree about Boswell himself. He's trying to present himself in these letters as a kind of a man of mystery. Yeah. He's the kind of man who would, I can picture him walking across Afghanistan. And then writing a book about it. Can you picture that? This has been hanging over the story from the beginning, hasn't it? The Alastair Campbell, Roy Strait, Dr. Johnson Boswell parallels.
这有点像，我想，你知道的，美国人在试图让特朗普支持泽连斯基一样。就是那种事。但当然，这也总在一定程度上关乎博斯韦尔本人。他试图在这些信件中把自己塑造为一个神秘人物。是的。他是那种会……我能想象他走过阿富汗，然后写了一本书的情景。你能想象吗？这件事从一开始就一直悬在故事的头顶，不是吗？阿拉斯加·坎贝尔、罗伊·斯特里特、约翰逊博士和博斯韦尔的相似之处。
Well, perhaps in build. Yeah. I mean, what I will say about Boswell is that he is much, much readier to confess in every lurid detail, everything that he's thinking and doing. Than Rory. Well, I think than pretty much anyone today, to be honest. Anyway, so Boswell is now returning home because Lord Affleck, I mean, absolutely dispeptic by this point, has sent him a letter saying, come back, don't bother seeing anything in France. There is nothing to be learned by traveling in France. He knows he's been there. Yeah. And so Boswell heads back. He's had this brilliant time. He's been hanging out with Rousseau. He's been hanging out with Voltaire. He's been a freedom fighter in Corska. And now he has to, you know, he faces the prospect of returning home and becoming an Edinburgh
嗯，也许在体形上是这样。是的。我的意思是，关于博斯韦尔，我想说的是，他要远远、远远更乐意坦白他脑子里的每一个疯狂细节，坦白他所想所做的一切。比起罗伊。嗯，说实话，我觉得他比当今的几乎任何人都更坦诚。不管怎样，博斯韦尔现在正准备回家，因为阿瑟克勋爵（此时已经消化不良、怒气冲冲）给他写了一封信，说：“回来吧，别费心去看法国的任何东西了。在法国旅行学不到任何东西。”他知道他去过那里了。是的。于是博斯韦尔踏上了回家的路。他度过了一段精彩绝伦的时光。他一直和卢梭混在一起，一直和伏尔泰混在一起，他曾是科西嘉岛上的自由战士。现在他不得不，你知道的，面对回到爱丁堡并成为一名爱丁堡
lawyer. However, on the bright side, going back to Britain, does have one positive. And that positive, of course, is Samuel Johnson. And Boswell has not forgotten Johnson while he was on his travels. He's thrilled to have met Rousseau. He's thrilled to have met Voltaire. But the whole way through, Johnson remains Boswell's moral touchstone. And throughout his journals, whenever he feels that he's slumping into depression or he's tempted to, you know, go out on the streets, spending money on prostitutes. He kind of reins himself in by saying, resemble Johnson, your mind will strengthen. And this is kind of, you know, he's always telling himself, be like Johnson, do what Johnson would do. These kind of pumping these kind of staccato imperatives. He has done what Dr. Johnson
律师的前景。然而，从光明的一面来看，回到英国确实有一个积极的方面。而这个积极的方面，当然就是塞缪尔·约翰逊。博斯韦尔在旅行时并没有忘记约翰逊。他很高兴能见到卢梭。他很高兴能见到伏尔泰。但自始至终，约翰逊依然是博斯韦尔的道德试金石。纵观他的日记，每当他觉得自己陷入沮丧或者经受不住诱惑（比如去街上把钱花在妓女身上）时。他总是通过对自己说“效仿约翰逊吧，你的意志就会坚强起来”来克制自己。这就像是，你知道的，他总是告诉自己：像约翰逊那样做，去做约翰逊会做的事。这些就像是不断地给自己下达一些短促的、断断续续的命令。他做了约翰逊博士
has done because ever since he left Johnson at Harwich, he has been able to fend off the foul feed of the genitals, no? Well, he had in Holland, which is one of the reasons why he was so depressed. in Germany and in Switzerland. When he talks to Rousseau, it's obvious that he has been trying to think of a way to square the circle. How can you have lots of sex with multiple women while remaining a Christian? And so he points out to Rousseau that in Genesis, the biblical patriarchs seem to have had lots of concubines.
做过的事，因为自从他在哈威奇离开约翰逊以来，他一直能够抵御生殖器的恶劣情绪，不是吗？嗯，他在荷兰时有过，这也是他在德国和瑞士时感到如此沮丧的原因之一。当他与卢梭交谈时，很明显他一直在试图想出一个办法来解决这个矛盾：你如何在与多个女性发生大量性行为的同时，还能保持一个基督徒的身份？于是他向卢梭指出，在《创世记》中，圣经里的族长们似乎有很多妃嫔。
And so he says to Rousseau, wouldn't this be a possibility? I mean, couldn't I just keep a harum like Abraham did? And he's obviously hoping that Rousseau will back him on this. And Rousseau does not, actually. So he's a bit disappointed by that. And then I said he arrives in Italy and misbehaves. I mean, he cracks very, very badly.
于是他对卢梭说：“这难道不是一种可能吗？我的意思是，难道我不能像亚伯拉罕那样建一个后宫吗？”他显然希望卢梭能在这件事上支持他。而卢梭实际上并没有支持他。所以他对此感到有点失望。然后我说他到了意大利并开始胡闹。我的意思是，他彻底堕落了。
So in Naples, he'd written, I was truly libertine. I ran after girls without restraint. And in Rome, he writes to Rousseau, I sallied forth of an evening like an imperious lion. He says, the sun is hot. It's inflamed my blood. I can't help myself. Right.
所以在拿坡里，他写道：“我真的成了一个浪荡子。我毫无节制地追逐女孩。”而在罗马，他写信给卢梭：“我在傍晚时分如同一个不可一世的狮子般大步流星地走出去。”他说：“太阳很热。它点燃了我的血液。我情不自禁。”没错。
What about Paris? So he gets to Paris. Does he behave himself in Paris? So this is 1766. He's 26 years old. He's about to turn 26. No, he doesn't. And in fact, things take a very dark turn
那巴黎呢？那么他到了巴黎。他在巴黎表现得规矩吗？所以这是1766年。他26岁了。他快要满26岁了。不，他没有。事实上，事情朝着非常黑暗的方向发展，
because he's been in Paris a week or so. And he picks up a Scottish newspaper that he finds there. And he reads to his horror, but his mother is dead. And he'd loved his mother. Yeah. So he's devastated by this. And so he vents this feeling of despair in a classic Boswell way by going to a brothel.
因为他在巴黎呆了一个星期左右。他在那里随手拿起一份苏格兰报纸。他惊恐地读到，他的母亲去世了。而他一直很爱他的母亲。是的。所以他对此感到痛不欲生。因此，他以一种典型的博斯韦尔式方式，通过去妓院来宣泄这种绝望的情绪。
That's how he copes with it. Of course he does. Also in Paris, amazingly, is Rousseau's mistress, Dorezler Vassur, who we last met in Switzerland. And she is in Paris because she is heading on to England and specifically to Chiswick in West London, where Rousseau has settled. And the reason that he's settled there is that he's been driven out of Switzerland by outraged locals. And the principal reason for their outrage is the fact that Rousseau, a man who, as we mentioned, is very keen and in. insistent on good parenting has recently been outed as having had these five children by his
他就是这样应对的。他当然会这样。同样在巴黎，令人惊讶的是，还有卢梭的情妇特蕾丝·勒瓦瑟，我们上次在瑞士见过她。她之所以在巴黎，是因为她正准备前往英国，具体来说是去伦敦西部的奇西克，卢梭在那里安顿了下来。他之所以在那里定居，是因为他被愤怒的当地人赶出了瑞士。而他们愤怒的主要原因是，卢梭这个我们前面提到过的、非常热衷且坚持良好育儿观念的人，最近被曝出他与情妇生下了这五个孩子，并将他们全都扔进了孤儿院。听上去真不像话，卢梭这样一个所有人中最不可能的人，竟然被揭露是一个伪君子。是的。因此他被赶出了瑞士，去英国避难，而特蕾丝现在正前往那里与他汇合。于是卢梭问博斯韦尔：“你愿意护送特蕾丝并把她带到我这里来吗？”博斯韦尔答应了，而他们不可避免地发生了性关系。起初，博斯韦尔因为跟卢梭的情妇发生性关系而过于紧张，以至于无法正常表现。
mistress and dumping them all in an orphanage. Don't sound with that Rousseau, of all people, has been exposed as a hypocrite. Yeah. And so he's been driven out of Switzerland and he's gone to take refuge in England and Therese is now traveling there to join him. And so Rousseau has asked Boswell, will you escort Therese and bring her to me? and Boswell does and inevitably they have sex. Initially, Boswell can't perform because he's so nervous about having sex with Rousseau's mistress.
但随后他设法做到了，进展得很激烈。所以特蕾丝说：“听着，我来教你几招。”于是他们在旅途中，在从巴黎到多佛的旅程中，上了12节课。特蕾丝对自己的表现极其满意。博斯韦尔却觉得无聊透顶。他甚至非常绅士地把特蕾丝比作一个骑马下坡技术糟糕的骑手。所以两人都未能满足。双方都感到有些失望。
But then he manages it, goes in hard. So Trey says, listen, I'll give you some lessons. And so they have 12 lessons between on the journey, on the journey from Paris to Dover. And Terez is incredibly pleased with herself. Boswell finds it really dull. And he gallantly compares Terez to a bad rider galloping downhill. So neither is satisfied. both of them have letting themselves down.
是的。所以，当博斯韦尔把特蕾丝送到奇西克的卢梭身边，然后急忙赶去与塞缪尔·约翰逊重聚时，这可能算是一种解脱。嗯，你永远不会指责约翰逊博士过于软弱无力或缺乏技巧，对吧？他十八般武艺样样精通。他确实如此。而且在他的熊般外表下，还蕴藏着这种人类的善良。是的。
Yeah. So it's probably some relief that Boswell drops to raise off with Rousseau in Chiswick and then goes rushing off to be reunited with Samuel Johnson. Well, you could never accuse Dr. Johnson of being either too flaccid or lacking art, could you? He's got all the arts. He has. And also he has this human kindness beneath his bearish exterior. Yeah.
他很高兴见到博斯韦尔，并且以极大的热情迎接了他，博斯韦尔如是说。但与此同时，约翰逊依然像头熊一样脾气暴躁。他对博斯韦尔进行了偶尔的猛烈抨击。博斯韦尔一直在滔滔不绝地讲述他的假期，喋喋不休地谈论他是如何见到卢梭的。约翰逊爆发了。我的意思是，卢梭可太不像塞缪尔·约翰逊了。所以他说：“卢梭先生，是个非常糟糕的人。”
And he's delighted to see Boswell and greets him with much kindness, Boswell says. but at the same time Johnson is bearish. He gives Boswell the occasional mauling. Boswell is talking all about his holidays and going on about how he's met Rousseau. Johnson explodes. I mean, Rousseau is so not Samuel Johnson. So he says, Rousseau, sir, is a very bad man.
“比起这些年来从老贝利法院走出去的任何重罪犯，我更愿意对他的流放判决签字画押。”是的，我真想让他去种植园里干活。对此，博斯韦尔（他已经变得非常擅长基本上用各种方式哄诱约翰逊，好让他说出更加惊世骇俗的言论）说：“先生，您觉得卢梭和伏尔泰一样是个坏人吗？”约翰逊对此回答道：“哎呀，先生，很难在他们两人的邪恶程度之间分出一个高下。”是的，约翰逊博士，我想我在上一集里说过这话，他会成为《每日快报》的一个了不起的专栏作家。他会做成一个非常棒的播客，对吧，我觉得。
I would soon assign a sentence for his transportation than that of any felon who has gone from the old Bailey these many years. Yes, I should like to have him work in the plantations to which Boswell, who's become very good at basically kind of coaxing Johnson along so that he'll come out with ever more outrageous statement, says, Sir, do you think Rousseau as bad a man as Voltaire, to which Johnson replies, Why, sir, it is difficult to settle the proportion of iniquity between them? Yeah, Dr. Johnson, I think I said this in the last episode, he would have made a tremendous columnist for the Daily Express. He does a wonderful podcast, wouldn't he, I think.
但这是一个充满尖刻情绪的播客。哦，完全是的。他的观点会非常坚定。我的意思是，毫无疑问。嗯，而且，作为一个例子，博斯韦尔在约翰逊对伏尔泰不屑一顾之后，又试图在约翰逊身上套用伏尔泰的那些异端邪说，对此约翰逊回应道：
But a very splenetic podcast. Oh, completely. He'd be robust in his views. I mean, no question. Well, and so, I mean, as an example of this, Boswell, after Johnson has dismissed Voltaire, then tries one of Voltaire's infidel sallies on Johnson, to which Johnson responds,
这简直就像我刚开始觉得自己是个聪明的家伙时跟我母亲说的那种废话，她本来应该为这狠狠地抽我一顿的。所以他基本上认为伏尔泰就是个青少年。是的。然后博斯韦尔开始抱怨他必须成为一名律师。他将成为一名律师定义为被那些死记硬背的笨蛋所超越。所以我不知道我们的法律听众会对此作何感想。
this now is such stuff as I used to talk to my mother when I first began to think myself a clever fellow, and she ought to have whipped me for it. So he basically thinks that Voltaire's a teenager. Yeah. And then Boswell starts moaning on about how he's got to become a lawyer. He defines being a lawyer as being excelled by plodding blockheads. So I don't know what our legal listeners will make of that.
而约翰逊再次，你知道的，他现在没时间理会这些，也没时间理会任何自怜自艾。没错。叫博斯韦尔像个男人一样振作起来。是的，但我的意思是，博斯韦尔现在确实得振作起来了，因为法律的地狱正在他面前张开。是的。我的意思是，基本上，从这一点开始，博斯韦尔将被锁死在法律职业生涯中。不会再有在科西嘉瞎晃荡或结识异端哲学家这回事了。于是他回到了苏格兰。他已经离开三年半了。但从现在开始，他的工作将是作为一名辩护律师实践。他定期这样做。他可靠地完成工作。他实际上做得相当不错。所以我觉得这有助益，实际上在苏格兰，博斯韦尔以辩护律师身份出庭的诉讼法院。一年只开庭六个月。这给博斯韦尔留出了相当多的时间去做其他事情，去追求其他的兴趣、其他的梦想。而其中最公开的
And Johnson again is, you know, he has no time for this now, for any self-pity. Right. tells Boswell to man up. Yeah, but I mean, Boswell does have to man up now because the legal hell is opening up before him. Yes. I mean, basically, from this point on, Boswell is going to be locked into a legal career. There's going to be no more tassing around Korsko or meeting Fidel philosophers. So he heads back to Scotland. He's been away for three and a half years. But from now on, his job is going to be to practice as an advocate. And he does it regularly. He does it reliably. He's actually quite good at it. So I think it helps that actually in Scotland the Court of Sessions before which Boswell is appearing as an advocate. It only sits for six months a year. So that gives Boswell quite a lot of time to do other things, see other interests, other dreams. And the most public
事情依然是他在为科西嘉独立进行积极奔走。所以他回去了。他没有忘记科西嘉。平心而论，他向多位英国大臣进行了交涉，包括老威廉·皮特，这是一位非常重要的人物。皮特说：“好的，我看看我能做些什么”，当然，什么也没做。博斯韦尔还将他在科西嘉的旅行写成了一本书并出版了，取得了巨大的成功。这为他赢得了“科西嘉的博斯韦尔”的绰号，他对此喜爱有加，并在日记中写道：“拥有像我这样的人设真是太棒了。我非常享受。”
of these remains his activism on behalf of Corsican independence. So he gets back. He hasn't forgotten Corsica. And to give him credit, he makes representations to various British ministers, including William Pitt the Elder, who's a very significant player. And Pitt says, yeah, I'll see what I can do, and of course, does nothing. Boswell also, he writes up his travels in Corsica as a book and it's published and it's a great success. And it wins him the nickname of Corsica Boswell, which he absolutely loves, and he writes about it in his journal, it is fine to have such a character as I have. I enjoy it much.
他对自己非常满意。多米尼克，你问过关于这套科西嘉服装的事情，他带回来了，他真的穿过吗？他真的穿了。机会出现在1769年9月，约翰逊的老朋友大卫·加里克（他那个时代最伟大的演员，他那个时代最伟大的莎士比亚戏剧演员）在莎士比亚的出生地斯特拉特福举办了一场莎士比亚戏剧节。
He's very pleased with himself. And Dominic, you asked about this outfit, of course, concludes that he's brought back with him and does he ever wear it? He does. And the opportunity comes in September 1769, Johnson's old friend David Garrick, the greatest actor of his day, the greatest Shakespearean actor of his day. stages a Shakespeare Jubilee in Stratford upon Avon, Shakespeare's birthplace.
哦，太棒了。这将是一场对这位诗人的盛大庆祝活动，预定持续三天。事实上，它在后来成为“莎士比亚崇拜”的现象中产生了巨大的影响。将莎士比亚视为至高无上的天才这一观念。加里克的戏剧节在其中发挥了关键作用，尽管事实上，我的意思是，这简直是一场泡汤的活动，因为在第二天，雨下得太大，以至于第三天的活动不得不直接取消。每个人都在泥地里跋涉，防水帆布也倒塌了，诸如此类。现场演出不得不取消。但去了那里的博斯韦尔却度过了一个美好的
Oh, nice. And it's going to be a great celebration of the bard, and it's scheduled to last for three days. And in fact, it has an enormous impact in kind of what becomes bardolatory. This notion of Shakespeare as the supreme genius. Garrick's Jubilee plays a key role in that, despite the fact that actually, I mean, it's literally a washout, because on the second day, so much rainfalls that the third day, simply has to be cancelled. And everyone's kind of tramping around in mud, the tarpaulins fall down, all of that. The live shows have to be cancelled. But Boswell, who has gone there, has a lovely
时光，因为他穿着他的科西嘉服装出现了。他在那里，带着他的枪、他的饰带以及诸如此类的一大堆东西。我的意思是，非常具有前拜伦式的风格。他朗诵了一首他自己写的关于科西嘉自由的诗。他对此写道：“我成了我所渴望的最受欢迎的人。”换句话说，莎士比亚戏剧节泡汤了，但博斯韦尔表现得极其出色。当然。所以在这场科西嘉-博斯韦尔式的
time because he has turned up in his Corsican costume. And there he, with his guns and his, you know, his sash and all that kind of stuff. I mean, very proto-Byrant. And he reads out a poem that he has written himself about Corsican liberty. And he wrote about it, I was as much a favourite as I could desire. In other words, Shakespeare Jubilee is a washout, but Boswell's been brilliant. Of course. So there are only two shadows on this kind of Corsica-Boswell
天堂里只有两个阴影。第一个阴影是，实际上科西嘉自由的梦想现在已经彻底破灭了，因为热那亚不再是科西嘉的女主人，因为法国人现在已经入侵了。而且，这现在变得至关重要，因为这解释了为什么从长远来看，拿破仑这个科西嘉人
heaven. The first is that actually the dream of Corsican liberty is conclusively over now because Jenna is no longer the mistress of Corsica because the French have now invaded. And of course, this is now, you know, this is crucial because this explains why in the long run Napoleon a Corsican
最终会成为法兰西皇帝。所以这是一个重大的历史发展。可怜的帕奥里将军，他不得不逃亡，流亡海外，并在戏剧节几天后抵达伦敦寻求政治庇护。博斯韦尔（平心而论）做得非常好。他把帕奥里介绍给约翰逊、他所有的朋友以及尽可能多的人。而帕奥里依然是博斯韦尔万神殿中最纯粹的英雄。因为约翰逊对这种科西嘉事务已经厌烦透顶了，不是吗？我的意思是，你能感觉到其他人实际上对博斯韦尔和他的科西嘉长裤是怎么看的。
will end up a emperor of the French. So it's a momentous development. And poor General Paoli, he has to flee, he goes into exile, and he turns up in London a few days after the Jubilee to claim political asylum. Boswell, again, to give him credit, he's really good. He introduces Powley to Johnson and to all his friends and to as many people as he can. And Pauli remains, I think, the kind of the purest hero in Boswell's pantheon. Because Johnson's sick of this Corsican business, isn't he? I mean, you get a sense of actually what other people made of Boswell and his Corsican trousers.
约翰逊是怎么说的？“把你的脑子清空，别再想科西嘉了，我想它把你的脑子塞得太久了。”所以我用他原本会有的地道的米德兰兹口音来模仿他。“科西嘉太多了，”他对博斯韦尔说。“别再唠叨科西嘉了。”但博斯韦尔知道，这种刻薄（你知道的）是不可避免的。这就是约翰逊的本色。在莎士比亚戏剧节前一年，博斯韦尔写下了一段精彩的文字。
What does Johnson say? Empty your head of Corsica, which I think has filled it rather too long. So I'm giving him the proper Midlands accent that he would have had. Yeah, too much of Corsica, he also says to Boswell. Shut up about Corsica. But Boswell knows that this kind of abrasiveness, you know, it comes with the territory. This is what Johnson's all about. And there's this kind of wonderful account that Boswell writes up a year before the Shakespeare Jubilee.
约翰逊是怎么说的？“把科西嘉岛从你脑子里赶出去，我想这个岛塞满你的脑袋太久了。”所以我给他配上了他本该有的地道的米德兰兹口音。是的，关于科西嘉岛的东西太多了，他也对博斯沃思这么说。闭嘴，别提科西嘉了。但博斯沃思知道，这种尖锐的态度，你知道的，是难免的。这就是约翰逊的特点。而且博斯沃思在莎士比亚诞辰庆典前一年写了一篇非常精彩的记述。
Boswell had dined with Johnson and various others in this pub on the Strand, the Crown and Anchor. And Johnson, the whole evening, had been in particularly rumbunctuous form. And Boswell writes, When I called upon Dr. Johnson next morning, I found him highly satisfied with his colloquial prowess the preceding evening. Well, said he, we have good talk. Boswell, aye sir, you tossed and gourd several persons. And that sense that Johnson's conversation often is about tossing and goring people, I think is part of what makes him such a compelling spectacle for Boswell. He kind of enjoys it. But Johnson doesn't really toss and gore Boswell too much, does he?
鲍斯韦尔曾在斯特兰德的这家名为“王冠与锚”的酒吧里与约翰逊及其他人共进晚餐。整个晚上，约翰逊都处于一种极为喧闹的状态。鲍斯韦尔写道：“第二天我去拜访约翰逊博士时，发现他对前一晚自己出色的口才感到十分满意。‘好吧，’他说，‘我们谈得很痛快。’我说：‘是啊，先生，您把好几个人驳得体无完肤。’”我认为，约翰逊的谈话常常带有戏弄和痛击别人的色彩，正是这一点，让他在鲍斯韦尔眼中成了一个如此引人注目的奇观。他某种程度上很享受这一点。不过，约翰逊对鲍斯韦尔其实并没有太过分，不是吗？
Because they remain tremendous friends. And there's an underlying kind of affection there, isn't there? I think the two aren't mutually exclusive. Johnson does toss and gore Boswell if he feels that he deserves it. But he's always ready to show Boswell that he loves him. Johnson can tell that Boswell not only loves him, but reveres him. And Johnson is human and he likes this. Even after Boswell gets married in 1769, he can't bear to kind of a bad.
因为他们依然是莫逆之交。这其中有一种潜藏的深厚情谊，对吧？我认为这两者并不排斥。如果约翰逊觉得鲍斯韦尔罪有应得，他确实会痛击鲍斯韦尔。但他总是随时准备向鲍斯韦尔表达他的喜爱。约翰逊能看出，鲍斯韦尔不仅爱戴他，而且对充满敬仰。约翰逊也是凡人，他很受用这一点。甚至在鲍斯韦尔于1769年结婚后，他依然无法忍受……
Johnson, to abandon London. And so he makes these regular trips down to the capital. He feels a bit guilty about it, but not guilty enough to stop doing it. And Boswell's friendship with Johnson means that even though he's now a Scottish lawyer, he does kind of remain at the heart of London literary life. This continues to make Boswell unbelievably happy. So there's a kind of wonderful moment in 1772. He's sitting with Johnson and with Johnson's friend on Oliver Goldsmith, who's a very celebrated Irish poet, novelist, playwright, she stooped to conquer. And as he had done with Rousseau, as he'd done with Voltaire, Boswell hugs himself. I mean, he says, he writes, he felt a completion of happiness.
约翰逊离开伦敦。因此他会定期去首都。他为此感到有点内疚，但内疚程度还不足以让他停下来。鲍斯韦尔与约翰逊的友谊意味着，尽管他现在是一名苏格兰律师，但他某种程度上依然处于伦敦文学界的核心。这继续让鲍斯韦尔感到无比快乐。所以1772年有一个非常美妙的时刻。他正和约翰逊以及约翰逊的朋友奥利弗·戈德史密斯坐在一起，后者是一位非常著名的爱尔兰诗人、小说家、剧作家，写过《屈身求爱》。正如他对卢梭、对伏尔泰做过的那样，鲍斯韦尔按捺不住内心的喜悦。我的意思是，他写道，他感到了幸福的圆满。
I just sat and hugged myself in my own mind. I think that's such a great, a great phrase. And the following spring, the seal is set on this kind of sense of joy of hugging himself in his mind. when Johnson proposes Boswell for membership of the single most exclusive society in the country, and it's known simply as the club. And this had been founded in 1764 by Johnson, by Joshua Reynolds, the great painter, by Edmund Burke, the politician. And by the time that Boswell gets elected in 1773, Oliver Goldsmith, who we just mentioned, he's a member, David Garrick, the actor is a member.
我只是坐在那里，在心里暗自欣喜。我觉得这是一个非常棒、非常绝妙的词。第二年春天，这种内心窃喜的幸福感得到了印证，当时约翰逊提名鲍斯韦尔加入这个国家最具排他性的单一社团，它简称为“俱乐部”。该俱乐部由约翰逊、伟大画家约书亚·雷诺兹以及政治家埃德蒙·伯克于1764年创立。到鲍斯韦尔于1773年当选时，我们刚刚提到的奥利弗·戈德史密斯已经是成员了，演员大卫·加里克也是成员。
Subsequent members will include Edward Gibbon, the historian, Sir Joseph Banks, who went with Captain Cook and was the first Englishman to go surfing. As Boswell puts it after his election, it is such a society as can seldom be found. So we talked about that in our very first episode for our rest is history club members. It's like the inspiration and history's greatest clubs. And here we are. Yeah, and here we are. With our very own club.
后来的成员将包括历史学家爱德华·吉本，以及曾随库克船长同行、成为第一个去冲浪的英国人的约瑟夫·在班克斯爵士。正如鲍斯韦尔在当选后所说，这是一个难得一见的社团。我们在“历史之余”俱乐部成员的第一期节目中谈到过这一点。这就像是灵感来源以及历史上最伟大的俱乐部。我们现在就在这里。是的，我们就在这里。拥有我们自己的俱乐部。
We've got more members than they had. That's true. Maybe not quite as exclusive. But we're just as exclusive. I was bad to say. We've got more members. and I think we've got a higher quotient of red trousers than they had. But as Tabby rightly says, we always want more members.
我们的会员比他们当时还要多。确实如此。也许没有那么排他。但我们同样排他。我刚想这么说。我们有更多的会员。而且我认为我们的红色裤子比例比他们当时更高。但正如塔比正确指出的那样，我们总是想要更多的会员。
We haven't got the best people. We want even better people. We do. Right. So let's finish with the get back away from the club to Johnson and Boswell. A striking thing is that this is an unbalanced friendship. So it's always Boswell who is sort of impotuning Johnson, not vice versa, right? It's Boswell who is paying court to the great man.
我们还没有最好的人选。我们想要更好的人选。确实如此。好吧，让我们回到正题，从俱乐部转回到约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔身上。一个引人注目的事实是，这是一段不对等的友谊。所以总是鲍斯韦尔在纠缠约翰逊，而不是反过来，对吧？是鲍斯韦尔在向这位伟人示好。
It's never the great man who is paying. some pain court to Boswell, or is it? It's true. Johnson has never been to Scotland. And of course, his quips about Scotland are notorious. So in his dictionary, he had notoriously defined oats as a grain, which in England is generally given to horses, but in Scotland supports the people. You know, you said, does Johnson ever toss and gore Boswell? Well, he does. So on one occasion, Boswell had commented, sometimes I have been in the humour of wishing to retire to a desert, to which Johnson had retorted, sir, you have desert enough in Scotland. Oh, that's great banter.
从来都不是这位伟人在向鲍斯韦尔示好，是吗？确实如此。约翰逊从未去过苏格兰。当然，他对苏格兰的讽刺也是出了名的。比如在他的词典中，他曾臭名昭著地将燕麦定义为：“在英格兰通常喂给马吃，但在苏格兰却用来养活人民的谷物。”你知道，你刚才说，约翰逊有没有痛击过鲍斯韦尔？嗯，有的。所以有一次，鲍斯韦尔评论说：“有时我有隐居荒野的冲动。”对此约翰逊反驳道：“先生，您在苏格兰已经有足够的荒野了。”哦，这真是绝妙的调侃。
So great banter. But we used the word performative in our previous episode. And I think that's the Mojus. Johnson is actually intrigued by Scotland. And he's been telling Boswell right from the beginning, I would actually like to come and see, you know, the castle on your estate. And saying, I would love to go to the Hebrides in particular because he'd been reading about them since he was a boy.
真是绝妙的调侃。但我们在上一集里用过“表演性”这个词。我认为这就是精髓所在。约翰逊其实对苏格兰很感兴趣。从一开始他就告诉鲍斯韦尔：“我其实很想来看看，你知道的，你庄园里的城堡。”他还说：“我特别想去赫布里底群岛，因为他从小就一直在阅读关于那里的书籍。”
Now, by 1773, which is the year that Boswell gets elected to the club, The prospects for such a jaunt must have seemed incredibly faint because Johnson is 64, he's got an inflamed eye, he's enormously fat. He's sunk in a kind of melancholy. But it seems that it's precisely this melancholy which resolved him that summer of 1773 that actually, yeah, I am going to give in to Boswell's kind of urgings. I will go to Scotland. And so on the 3rd of August, he wrote to Boswell in Edinburgh, sir, I shall set out from London on Friday the 6th of this month and propose not to loiter much by the way. So the adventure is on.
到了1773年，也就是鲍斯韦尔当选俱乐部成员的那一年，这样一次远足的前景看起来一定极其渺茫，因为约翰逊已经64岁了，患有眼疾，体型极其肥胖。他陷入了一种忧郁之中。但似乎正是这种忧郁，让他在1773年那个夏天痛下决心：其实，好吧，我要顺从鲍斯韦尔的规劝。我要去苏格兰。于是8月3日，他在爱丁堡写信给鲍斯韦尔：“先生，我将于本月6日星期五从伦敦出发，并打算在路上不要过多耽搁。”于是，历险开始了。
Samuel Johnson is coming to Scotland and the most famous literary expedition in British history is about to begin. God, what excitement. What a cliffanger. Unbelievable. So next week we will be exploring the story of this tremendous expedition which dwarfs anything accomplished
萨缪尔·约翰逊即将来到苏格兰，英国历史上最著名的文学探险即将开始。天哪，多么令人兴奋。多么引人入胜的悬念。令人难以置信。所以下周我们将探讨这次宏大探险的故事，它相形见绌了历史上任何伟大探险家所取得的成就……
by the great explorers of history, the conquistadors and so on. We'll be doing that next week and in our final episode we'll be telling the story of how the friendship came to an end. And what happened to Boswell and Johnson. Now, we've mentioned our club a few times. I think not inappropriately and I think very, very subtly and judiciously. I'm just going to mention it one more time because if you would like to join our equivalent of the club, the club that was formed by Johnson, Joshua, Reynolds and Edmund Burke,
比如那些征服者等等。我们下周会讲到这些，而在我们的最后一期节目中，我们将讲述这段友谊是如何走向终结的。以及鲍斯韦尔和约翰逊后来怎么样了。现在，我们已经多次提到我们的俱乐部。我认为这并非不合时宜，而且我认为非常非常巧妙且明智。我只想再提一次，因为如果你想加入我们这个相当于俱乐部的组织——那个由约翰逊、约书亚·雷诺兹和埃德蒙·伯克创立的俱乐部——
If you would like to join luminaries of a very, very similar nature, then you can join the club at the Restis History.com and you can hear next week's episodes right now. You don't have to wait. You don't have to bite your nails and gnash your teeth over the weekend, waiting for the next episodes. You can join that club. You can feel part of a light-minded community of polymaths, scholars and libertines.
如果你想加入那些非常、非常相似的名流之列，那么你可以在 TheRestisHistory.com 加入这个俱乐部，你现在就可以听到下周的节目。你不用等。你不用在周末急得咬牙切齿、咬牙切齿地等待接下来的节目。你可以加入那个俱乐部。你可以感觉自己是一个由博学者、学者和放荡不羁者组成的志同道合的社区的一部分。
And everything will be tremendous and you'll be much happier for it. So Tom, thank you very much. And we'll see you in Scotland. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hello, it's William Drupal again from Empire. Here is a clip from our recent six-part series on Mao Zedong. The Greatly Forward was supposed to be on its face a kind of highly rationalised bureaucratic system
一切都会好起来的，你会为此感到更加幸福。汤姆，非常感谢你。我们在苏格兰见。再见。再见。大家好，我是来自《帝国》节目的威廉·德鲁普尔。以下是我们近期关于毛泽东的六集系列节目的一个片段。大跃进表面上应该是一种高度理性化的官僚体制……
of working out what China could produce and then, you know, working upwards so that you would produce, you know, enough food for everyone to eat and crops that could then be exported to increase China's GDP and everything would be great. But basically, because all the figures are being fiddled by officials who are too terrified to give the real information in case they get arrested or, you know, kind of fired from their jobs. They pass on statistics upwards saying, yes, it's all going great, and we're kind of producing huge amounts of grain and products. And up, you know, in the cities and then, you know, beyond that to Beijing, the guys at the top are saying, oh, well, this is great. Well, in that case, we can export lots to the Soviet Union.
计算出中国能够生产什么，然后，你知道的，向上调整，这样你就能生产出，你知道的，足够所有人吃的食物，以及可以出口以增加中国GDP的农作物，一切都会很好。但基本上，由于所有的数据都被官员们篡改了，他们吓得不敢提供真实信息，生怕被捕或者，你知道的，被开除。他们把统计数据往上报，说，是的，一切都进展顺利，我们正在生产大量的粮食和产品。然后，你知道的，在城市里，再然后，你知道的，到北京，高层的人们说，哦，好吧，这太棒了。好吧，既然如此，我们可以向苏联出口大量物资。
So you have the kind of obscenity of out in the countryside, there isn't enough food for people to eat, while the grain is being seized and exported from the country to bring in money for the state. This is very much a rural phenomenon, and that's significant, because of course, shortly before this, the system which still exists today was started up in China. It was sort of Soviet-style internal passport system. It's called a Hokko or a household registration scheme. And it basically means that you can't just simply wander around wherever you want in China. You have to sort of have internal permission. So people in the cities were no longer really kind of interacting that much with the countryside. They were kind of almost separated off. And while people in the cities, you know, found there was a certain amount of deprivation, the devastation was really out in the countryside, where, where essentially it turned into mass starvation, about 1959, 1960, 61, it became clear in the countryside there simply wasn't enough food to go around. But when the news came through to the top
于是你就会看到这样一种荒谬的景象：在农村，人们没有足够的食物吃，而粮食却被搜罗并出口到国外，以为国家换取外汇。这在很大程度上是一种农村现象，这很重要，因为当然，在此之前不久，至今仍然存在的制度在中国开始了。这是一种苏联式的内部护照制度。它被称为“户口”或户籍制度。这基本上意味着你不能随心所欲地在中国到处闲逛。你必须获得某种内部许可。因此，城市里的人们不再真正与农村有太多互动。他们几乎被隔离开来。虽然城市里的人们，你知道的，发现有一定的物资匮乏，但破坏真正发生在农村，在那里，基本上演变成了大规模饥荒，大约在1959年、1960年、1961年，农村很明显根本没有足够的食物供大家分配。但是当消息传到高层……
leadership, including Mao, he basically chose to ignore it. He didn't exactly deny it, but he basically said, well, you know, we need to keep going. And he said something like, if things are not going so well, then let's just not say anything about it and keep going. And that led to one of the great confrontations of that period, which is the conference, Communist Party top-level conference held at Luzan. We hope you enjoyed that clip to listen to the full series Search Empire World History, wherever you get your podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
领导层，包括毛泽东，他基本上选择忽视它。他没有确切地否认，但他基本上说，好吧，你知道的，我们需要继续前进。他说过类似这样的话：如果事情不太顺利，那我们就不谈了，继续前进吧。这就导致了那个时期的一场重大对抗，也就是在庐山召开的共产党高层会议。希望你喜欢这个片段，想要收听完整系列，请在你的播客应用中搜索 Empire World History。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。